education committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a subcommittee
work session of the education committee
to address hb2 the section dealing with
the merger of the community college
system and the university system New
Hampshire please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously uh to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporary ously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar of the
general court
website the notice for this
meeting with house rules n RSA
912718 or email 8 H CS ledge. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that is are
assisting us with this meeting at this
time we have Jennifer four our research
uh committee researcher please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by rule call vote
we will not be taking any votes in in
this particular
meeting let's start the meeting and to
start I will call the role of uh
subcommittee members please when you
have your name called will you say uh
please State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under our right to law
no so with that I will call the role um
representative uh Mike Moffett uh alone
here in Louden thank you representative
uh uh Oliver Ford blone here in Chester
New Hampshire thank you very much
representative Mel Miler alone in kukk
New Hampshire thank you representative
David luno reporting from Hopkinson with
your dog with Aussie with Aussie the
long-hair docks that's great okay
representative art Ellison uh I'm alone
here in conquered and I am
representative Rick lad and I also have
my dog snoring at my feet so with that
we're all present today um we also have
a guest with us today Barbara Brit ham
and Barbara comes with as a wealth of
experience uh with dealing with higher
education and the accreditation process
associated with that uh does everybody
have copies of the materials I believe
that Barbara sent us um the other
day from Nei yeah yes yes okay great so
Barbara um I know you're a very busy
individual and working with institutions
throughout our our region our state and
the world um uh I don't have the the key
information to explain your background
and where what you are but perhaps you
could give us some background of of the
the position that you have your
experience your background in working
with higher education throughout the
throughout the world great thank thank
you representative ladin it's a pleasure
to be with you all I am alone I don't
have a dog I'm in what I refer to as the
other Cambridge across the river from
Boston and it's a pleasure to be with
you I wish we were together in person um
in July I retired as president of uh the
New England Commission of higher
education uh which accredits 220
colleges and universities in the six New
England states and um 11 American style
institutions in other countries um
before that I was on the staff there um
before that I worked in Dubai um in the
United Arab Emirates as uh at zad
University which is a new which was then
a new National University for local
women um I'm on the quality board in uh
Iceland which is the quality assurance
agency there and quality and
qualifications Ireland which plays a
similar function um in that country um
I'm also on the board of the national
student Clearing House which collects
data and makes it available um about
student enrollment and retention if
you've seen um press releases or news
articles recently about enrollment being
down during the um pandemic um those
probably came from the national student
claring house um Nei is recognized um by
the federal government that's the that's
the verb used in the higher education
act as quote a reliable Authority as to
the quality of education and through
that recognition it becomes a gatekeeper
for federal financial aid for students
so students in your institutions that uh
have pel grants or Federal loans it's
because of that
recognition uh accreditation in the US
provides quality assurance to the public
this is an okay place to go or to send
your son or daughter and if it works
well um it provides quality improvement
for institutions and
systems I've also written and um and
presented about public higher education
systems I find them fascinating um I
don't know any other country that has
anything quite like that so I want to
make a few remarks probably about 10
minutes and um and then look forward to
your questions and
observations uh I did watch your session
on Wednesday and I'm impressed with how
seriously you're taking the question
before you this this would be a
significant change um for the two
systems for the faculty the students and
for the State of New Hampshire um it's
as Joe morone outlined this is a very
challenging time for higher education
overall and certainly in New England uh
and as Susan Huard uh talked about it's
certainly two different systems in terms
of missions of Institutions and and
levels of programs so I'm not going to
offer you an opinion on whether ing
these systems is a good idea um but I'm
going to give you some comments and
observations and free opinions about um
what it looks like to me if you do go
forward with a merger um first of all
with respect to accrediation um you can
find the accreditation standard um on
our website if it would be helpful to
you I'd certainly be happy to have
copies mailed to each of you
um based on how seriously you're taking
this and um and the expertise within the
the systems already I don't anticipate
any problem going forward but the
standards can be a good overall guide as
you bring the two standard systems
together to make sure they work well um
I would advise that you and the system
stay in touch with Nei um they have
something called an advisory opinion
which is um sort of um institutions or
systems asking a question if we did this
what would you think and it's designed
um as part of what I used to call the
surprise Reduction Program um you don't
want the accreditor to surprise you and
the accreditor doesn't want you
surprising them so it's a formalized way
to stay in touch um in addition to the
informal mechanisms um likely if you do
go ahead and merge the systems uh the
commission will consider it to be a
substantive change which is a term of
art from The Higher Education Act and
they will approve it and that's also um
in in your favor in the sense that once
they approve it they've given you the
go-ahead on how you plan to go forward
um that again part of the surprise
Reduction Program but probably also
required um I want to talk a little bit
about the board composition and the
proposal that I have seen of um five
board members from four-year
institutions five from the two-year
institutions five by the governor
without nomination and ex eight ex
officios um my I two main observations
about that one in my opinion that is way
too many EX
officios um it's more common uh in other
states to have the chancellor as an ex
officio and the head of the K12 system
generally both
nonvoting um if you're going to have
more uh EX officios in that I would give
you my strong encouragement to have them
be non-voting um you and also you want
the perspective of the state agencies
and good communication with them but
there are other ways to get that one is
through regular scheduled meetings and
communication mechanisms another is to
think of those people as serving on
subcommittees of the board where their
expertise is particularly relevant to
task of that task of the
subcommittee my second main observation
about the proposed composition of the
board is um that
um the problem having people quote come
from two-year institutions and four-year
Institutions and maybe that is necess NE
probably is necessary initially because
of the Urgent amount of work that needs
to be done but but soon I would
encourage you to set up a mechanism that
the board looks at the whole and knows
the new entity and doesn't bring the
before with them um so they're invested
in the new that's the entity they get to
know um fiduciaries are trustees are
fiduciaries and it's important for the
success of the system
that they have the interest of the
entire system in in their mind um people
are human beings um which is true you
know everywhere I've been um and they
they will know how they got to the board
if they quote come from two-year
institutions or come from four-year
institutions or from that
perspective um I want to talk for a
minute now about um the next statement
that I hope you got and hope you got a
chance to take a look at this was
developed with the system heads when I
was um working for the commission I used
to meet with system heads twice a year
and um this grew out of the
conversations that we had and it was um
a statement that was approved by the
commission for system heads to be able
to give to Governors and say Here's
here's Collective wisdom of the
commission and of the system heads about
appointing people to um governing boards
for systems um it outlined some kinds of
expertise that's important Financial
expertise legal people in complex
systems people with a higher education
background people who understand risk
management um I think that I want to
just stop and emphasize that complex
system for a minute I was talking to
another to a chancellor of an an unnamed
State who said that there are a lot of
small businesses in that state and um
the governor tended to point point
people who had um worked in small
businesses which are obviously important
to the state important to the economy um
in all kinds of ways but there weren't
enough people who understood the
complexity of an organization like the
system and that was a
problem um the recommendation is that
you look for people that have executive
level experience in the public private
and voluntary sectors um and another
reason is for not having people in the
in the short term after the very short
term come from Two and fouryear
institutions is that as you as your
discussion indicated on Wednesday in a
very few years you may have a different
composition of Institutions that you
have now and I think you would be wise
not to lock yourself into um that
bifurcation over time clearly clearly
all the institutions need to feel that
there are people on the board who
understand them and understand their
perspective so it's not an argument
against that it's an argument against
locking yourself into a composition and
having people appear to come from a
certain sector
um um there's a question about who votes
um ex official members in in some places
the chancellor votes the president's
vote the students vote The Faculty vote
um I would argue none of those people
should vote they should all you know
whoever you choose to have an ex
official member the the voting members
should be the
fiduciaries
um the board appointments are made by
the governor that that is generally
common I think there are a few states
where legislators make the appointment
in more States the governors make the
appointment and there's some
ratification process by a legislative
committee such as yours or a legislative
chamber um so legislators you all are
elected to represent a constituency and
in the best of all possible worlds um
board members are not they're there to
represent not a constituency perhaps a
perspective but expertise and the
ability to look at the whole and and
look out for the common good um
fiduciaries have responsibil duties of
care and loyalty and obedience so you're
looking for expertise and um
understanding the mission of the various
kinds of Institutions but that's not the
only factor it's one of many and as I
was thinking about this I was reminded
of what we used to do and I hope this is
a helpful analogy to you um when it came
time to elect new Commissioners who
served for no more than two threeyear
terms um so we would make a little
spreadsheet every year my um senior vice
president and I and we would put down
who was who was going to be there after
the people who were leaving were gone um
and we wanted representation from the
Six States um plus they've recently
added International perspective from the
um overseas institutions we wanted role
representation presidents CFOs academics
people who looked after students people
who understood distance learning we we
added Rec added board members so Cass
ardinger who's a trustee of the
University system and New Hampshire is a
is a commissioner um and we recently
added from time to time have had system
heads and Todd leech is on the
commission right now um Wanted
commission needed people from public and
private institutions from large and
small from the wealthy institutions and
the Not So wealthy demography was
important men and women uh race and
ethnicity were um considered we wanted
people who had um some of the people who
had good experience shairing or serving
on teams so they understood the task of
what was going on and by law one out of
every members um must be a public member
and in fact right now the chair of the
commission is a public member
commission's had lawyers journalists and
and um people who had served on higher
ed boards but weren't currently
serving so um if you hire the right
Chancellor um if the board hires the
right Chancellor that person will be
invaluable in helping the governor um
select board members and then I found
and I hope you got it also um a
statement by the Association of
governing boards which is a Washington
membership Organization for people who
serve on public and independent Boards
of um
trustees um and they came out with a
statement that um gives you some op
suggest some options there for your
consideration one is to have and I'm not
I'm not endorsing any of these but I
wanted to put some options in front of
you and and there's some wise people who
worked on that one is to think of having
a nominating committee of citizens one
is to have some of the board be
self-perpetuating and in other words
nominated by the board themselves um it
talks about the personal characteristics
that you'd be looking for and not just
the expertise it it emphasizes that
point about um keeping it from being
political you all and the governor are
the politicians the board members are
the
fiduciaries and um to make sure that
public higher education in New England
in New Hampshire in New England is the
best it can possibly be so the main role
of the of the board is to hire and
support the chancellor and to hold the
chancellor accountable that that's the
main thing they do just as institution
boards their main role is to hire and
support the president and hold the
president accountable they need to make
sure collectively that they set the
priorities for the institutions in the
system that they do strategic planning
that they have wise use of resource and
they can hold the institutions and the
chancellor accountable a for the
outcomes
um you need I I would encourage that you
write this in such a way that the
chancellor has sufficient Authority um
and one question that sometimes comes up
is should the president's report to the
board or to the chancellor and my advice
is that they um report to the chancellor
because you want the board to have
remember these are volunteers um as you
practically are so you want the board to
have enough time to focus on their main
duties um they can be privy to the
evaluation of the um of the presidents
they certainly have a role in hiring
them and um determining their contract
but the direct reporting I think is from
my observation best done to the
chancellor um finally I'm getting close
to wrapping up here there's a lot of
work to bring the two systems together I
was uh involved with the main system
when they moved to single accreditation
I watched how much time that took them
I'm watching and have been in touch with
Vermont right now which is combining
three of this of the institutions in its
um public system um there needs to be
and you heard it on Wednesday um
opportunity to bring the technological
systems together and the purchasing and
all of the kind of back office things
that's important um my in my observation
this is going to take some time and it's
going to take some ex expertise of
people inside the system and outside the
system um outside help so that they can
learn from the wisdom of others and
their experience um a possibility two
possibilities for your consideration and
the new systems consideration are Jim
paage who's been working with Vermont
and led the main system for for I think
seven years and also enims the national
Center for higher education Management
Systems which is the uh author the paper
that I think you have about community
colleges but they're they're they're
neutral they they worked with a lot of
systems around the country um in terms
of extra support I believe the Vermont
system is getting about $8 million to
help it in the first year um and and um
and possibly more after that um there
was elusion to in the in the reason for
doing this in some discussion Wednesday
as I recall the transfer of credit issue
and I think that is um a a very
important issue um it's not something
that has done well in this country in my
opinion um I have served EX oficio on a
trans a task force on transfer by the
American council of education which is
the umbrella group in Washington for
higher education their report is coming
out this coming week and it emphasizes
um the importance of getting the
transfer issue done correctly on the
task force when we heard the staff
present you know the first um highlight
level ideas of what they were wanted the
report to say um there were several of
us ex officio but the task force members
themselves were college and university
presidents and they uniformly said make
it more urgent this this is really
important we we need to ramp up the
language and get people to pay attention
to
this
finally um I will say although I know
you know it that there are reputational
issues for public higher education in
New Hampshire for doing what you what
you are proposing to do um to make sure
that the higher ed system has sufficient
autonomy that the chancellor can serve
as CEO that there is support from the
legislature on how to get there that the
legisl legislature reflects confidence
in public higher education um and its
importance to the not only the state's
economy but it's to its Civic and
cultural life as well so um I I wish you
the very best I look forward to your
questions and if I can be of any help to
you at all going forward I'm I'm happy
to do
that thank you very much Dr brittenham
uh you indicated you'd be willing to
take questions that's correct yes
absolutely I I do have one and then uh
I'll I'll I'll have the committee have
some further uh when we are talking
about this uh broad uh uh new uh system
involving a different board uh five5 and
five uh and the chancellor reports
directly to that board and presidents
report directly and are accountable to
the
chancellor um in our system we currently
have 11 Community College seven
community colleges and we have four uh
uh with Granite State we have four
University level uh programs that's a
total of 11 um now if the chancellor is
going to have direct responsibility for
the presidents of all 11
institutions is there need in our form
of governance to have for example a vice
Chancellor uh an individual I know as a
previous administrator myself if you
have to evaluate and look at performance
and also be responsible for all those
fiscal
matters uh I don't know how one chanc is
going to do it um and also uh and the
second part of that question yes we we
are initially merging community college
and university system so there are those
mission statements associated with each
right now would it be wise to have a
vice Chancellor that has more um uh
understanding and perhaps uh awareness
of our community college system so
there's uh working with the chancellor
the we don't sort of put the community
couch in in the back of the room well
thank you that's a great question you
don't want to put the community college
in the back room but it's also um at
least theoretically possible that the
chancellor has a community college
background and what you would need in
that case is somebody that has a um a
four-year graduate background so I you
know the I think you're the premise of
your question is is excellent about you
know looking after an evaluating 11
presidents is going to be um a
significant deal um so you do want to
provide the chancellor with some support
that will B balance his or her and
extend his or her expertise and
background generally there's a chief
academic officer a Chief Financial
Officer um legal counsel um often some
someone with expertise in in HR um so I
would encourage you there are some
organizations of systems there are two
of them that come to mind and one of
them is shio the State Higher Education
executive officers and the other is Nash
the National Association of system heads
they and enms could be helpful to you in
looking at systems of similar size and
complexity um enms could be helpful
there J paage could be helpful there
looking at that and giving you some
thoughts about you know what's what's an
appropriate size and uh range of
expertise that the chancellor would need
to be helpful but your question is good
a good one uh one one question for our
um committee researcher Jen did you get
the names of the organ organizations
that uh Dr britam just
referenced I didn't scribble them all
down no
Jennifer why don't you write to me you
know and I'll be happy absolutely okay
yes thank you thank you very much doctor
um are there questions from the
committee at this
time yes represent luno thank thanks
very much um uh Rick and and thank you
Dr brittingham for joining us this
morning um I took a lot to not and and
your the information I think you you you
you bring forward's been been really
very helpful um I sort of wanted to step
back a little bit you you um you you
said you you watched the um uh the
meeting we had I think it was on was on
Wednesday or Monday this week I don't
remember what yeah um when uh when um I
think it was chair Marone was was really
laying out um the uh the problems that
both the the um university system as
well as the community col college system
we're facing you know in terms of
enrollment and there's been lots of you
know know you know it's not just a New
Hampshire problem um you know clearly
but um but but obviously both systems
are going to need to make some
adjustments in order to um to to address
that and to and to provide you know a
path forward for um for you know uh you
know sustainability and making sure that
that they can continue to meet the needs
of um of uh you know Granite sters uh
but um but leading up to um I I don't I
don't even want to say leading up to the
problem I guess what I'm wondering is
what would what would like a decision
tree look like for deciding whether or
not merger is needs to be something
that's done either prior to solving a
problem or in parallel with with solving
um the problem well it could depend on
what the problem is of course um you
know I think uh as I look at New England
states if you know if you can do a
thought experiment and there were no
systems and no institutions of higher
education but roughly the population and
the economy and whatever of the States
you wouldn't set it up the way it is in
many cases and Connecticut is a great
example Connecticut doesn't have a large
footprint and they have 12 separate
community colleges and um and and they
are um looking to merge them into a
single Community College I'm not
suggesting that as a solution but my
point is I think if you were if you
stick with that thought experiment and
say you're going to set up community
colleges in Connecticut how are you
going to do it you probably wouldn't
have 12 totally independent ones today
so I think um I think thinking about you
know what makes sense today and figuring
out how to get from here to there
um I I think I think that's a a key
issue is you know that the the question
you ask is a very good one I'm not sure
I can give you a very good answer off
the top of my head but I think figuring
out the timing and what you can do when
and how to keep how to keep the
institutions and the systems Now
supported until something else happens
assuming something else will happen
because life is going to go on you know
and um hopefully everybody will be back
on campus if they want to be back on
campus in the fall but this is still
going to be disruptive times and I was
also struck and I had found the numbers
from something else I'm writing about
the um the high number of high school
graduates from New Hampshire who leave
the state and I think you know I I would
encourage you to think about that as a
priority how can we do this in a way
that keeps more of our bright students
here hopefully to help New Hampshire in
the long run to keep your talent here
you want to attract outside talent but
you don't want to lose you know too much
of your current
Talent right um no thank thanks very
much thank thank you very much further
questions represent Miler uh thank you
Rick and thank you for being here this
morning uh the uh data that we got on
Wednesday was very
sobering and there is this sense of the
sky is
falling uh and I think the sense of the
sky is falling is representative in the
governor's proposal to try to merge the
system via the budgetary
process and the question that I have for
you is
um in this Panic state that we're in how
does one step
back and go slow to go fast go slow
enough that's right well I mean you set
up a group to plan it so that they come
back to you with a a a stronger
recommendation that would be one
possibility I again I'm sure enims could
give you other possibilities for this um
I think you want um I think you need to
think about what is it from what you've
heard what you read what you know what
you know of New Hampshire of some um
characteristics of what you would be
looking for um and you know it may be
one characteristic would be a strong
Chancellor CEO one characteristic might
be um you know um uh the emphasis that
came first from the governor as I read
things on making sure that students more
students go from two-year and complete
bachelor's degree if that's a priority
to you then I would put you know put the
sake in the ground and set up you know
five seven some number of key points and
take a year to design it okay um perhaps
while searching for a Chancellor if
you're committed to making it go through
um I think I think you could done well I
think you would have a great talent pool
to come here um it's a New Hampshire's a
wonderful State I don't have to tell you
that and this is these are challenging
times and this could be an exciting
opportunity for somebody who wants to
get this right what what your priorities
you know I think one of the for example
and I think it would it's likely true in
New Hampshire as well is to make sure
look after the community college and
also look after your research
University um and and that's kind of and
you've got you know some in between
there and granite States got an very
interesting record so you've got a a
really good array and and part of what I
hope you would want to do is to make
sure that the missions of the different
kinds of Institutions that you have are
are supported and recognize and find a
good home in the in a new system that
you would create so follow
Rick so from what I hear you saying is
that there is a need to do some
evaluation some
assessment some
planning
prior to making any kind of a
significant merge that would lock the
state in to a system that hasn't gone
through that pre-planning pre-planning
process is that correct I think that's
correct I mean one thing you hopefully a
goal that you have is to get it right so
that they don't right back to you and
saying we need to change the law because
working right you've got other things to
do and so the the what you can do to
make it you know to increase your
likelihood that you get it as right as
possible when you pass it um and that
doesn't mean you couldn't do something
intermediary set up something to make it
happen to come back to you in a year
um it kind of goes back to to a concern
that I would have is said where you have
ready fire aim rather than Ready Aim
Fire and it's the it's the aiming fi
it's the aiming process that needs to
take some time even within this Panic
state that we're in right now to make
sure that we get it right yeah uh when
we finally come thank you for your
thoughts yeah represen
Ellison can you hear me artart you're
you're you're muted
art there you go thank you I got it
thank you R thank you doctor for being
here today just a question we're talking
about a complicated process going
forward would you have some sense of who
the key groups are that should be
involved in this process I know that's
could be a long answer to a broad
question but any idea of who the key
people are or groups that ought to be
inv involved in what's going on well
sure obviously you all um I think the
the current systems the institutions um
the um the the ex officials that were
suggested by the governor you know they
they clearly have a perspective and and
a stake in making sure that this works
so listening to people from different
sectors Community you know um an open
process I think can help give a message
reinforce your message that this is
really important work um there are
probably alumni groups I don't know if
the various institutions or programs
have advisory groups um um you know in
Maine where they have the University
main system of credits this depending on
how you count six or seven um
institutions they rotate their meetings
go around and and have a regional
meetings so that they can listen to
people uh from different regions so you
want and the community colleges
illustrate that the importance around
the state um of the high public higher
education thank
you thank you uh representative Oliver
Ford Mr chairman thank you Dr brittenham
uh a question for you about the I'm
looking at the AGB statement suggestions
recommendations for Governors and
legislators yep um you had referred to
them and earlier in one of your remarks
yes and it's not so much the specifics
of that though they're obviously very
interesting but the sort of expectation
that we could create an entirely
apolitical um somewhat idealistic group
uh to be over the university system in a
highly politicized environment prior to
coming to New Hampshire I was in
Minnesota and Pennsylvania and
Massachusetts all of them highly
political and every one of those things
that we're involved in had a lot of
political interplay if you to put it in
polite terms yeah
um any Enlightenment you could share
with us if I'm your experience of
working around these things of how we
can acknowledge what we necessarily have
to acknowledge but still move to a
somewhat more ideal State apart from
that yes I think that's a great
observation about one of the main
messages there and you know given um who
worked on it I'm sure that was in part
of reaction to things that they had seen
where that wasn't F involved I live for
25 years in Rhode Island and God knows
there's no politics there so maybe you
would look to
that I think you know the um the idea of
having um that citizen nominating
committee is one one possibility I'm not
endorsing it but you know there you
could set up a composition that is at
least Le balance um and um look at it
that way I think um terms are another
way to do it because politics change so
you're going to get some of it you got
yeah you got human beings here but so
the thing that you can do is to take
look at that paper and say are there
ideas in there that make sense for New
Hampshire now that we can um at least
have small P political and not capital P
political in
there thank
you representative Moffet thank you Mr
chair thank you Dr bringham for being
with us today I took like represent luno
I have lots of notes as well thank you
um I I spent seven years in the
University system or 12 if you count my
five years as an undergrad and I also
spent 20 years in the community college
system so I know a bit about the two
different cultures yeah and here's
something that I see is a is a problem
going forward is that the 55 breakdown
uh
education uh was saying there's very
hierarchical and I completely expect uh
given the better the greater numbers in
the University system compared to the
community college system I I'm telling
you the folks in the University system
going to be saying well you know we're
under represented in terms of per capita
uh you I think you're tracked me a
little bit right so I don't know if that
can be counted by the appointees to skew
it towards the university any thoughts
on on that
Dynamic yeah I I would you know I again
I I think having some representation and
you might even think about writing this
into a law somehow about making sure
there's an immediate appointment that
ensures some enough continuity but also
brings in some New Perspectives and then
think about how to do it in language
that ensures appropriate
representation um if you put criteria
for who should be on the board
considerations analogous to those
criteria that I recited from what Nei
does you want you know you want
sufficient representation of x y and z
um which was never Quantified it didn't
mean that there had to be you know three
CFOs on the commission there needed to
be enough and so if there was a
president who'd been a CFO we knew we
had Financial expertise in that person
so I think coming up with a list of
General overall criteria that you're
looking for um and using words like
sufficient um
and and staying away from numbers at
least after the first
appointments sure thank you you know
hopefully when transfer gets better
you'll have people who um on the on the
Board of Trustees who have been at the
community college and went on to get you
know foury year and and maybe a graduate
degree so they've seen it all yeah thank
thank you uh representative mofet uh
dror I have uh a couple other questions
having uh served on behalf of speaker on
the trustees at the University system
New Hampshire uh about four or five
years ago um we were starting to see
issues uh surfacing in terms of
duplicity of programming um from the
community college to the four-year
system and amongst the four-year system
as well um at what point or let me start
that question a little differently other
states I'm sure have had the same
experience
um how have they addressed that uh
there's a lot of ownership in all these
local communities well we have a nursing
program here and we can't let go of that
and jobs are related to it etc etc but
in the long run uh Joe Moran presented
some real uh startling figures to us
this this decreasing demographic that
we've lost 20% of our population in the
last 20 years we've gone from like uh
220,000 K through 12 students down to
about 160,000 students 165,000 students
and that's projected to continue to
decrease and you spoke earlier of yes
we're exiting more kids out of the state
to go to a higher education than we're
retaining in our own state so we have
some
significant issues which we have to
address uh so in doing so we're looking
at a possible merger here but how do we
address this issue of duplicity and
programming and Facilities throughout
this teeny State of New
Hampshire thank you that's a great
question too um first of all um there
are somewhere between 23 and 28 I don't
remember the number of states that have
allow two-year institutions to do some
four-year degrees I'm not suggesting
that's a good idea and they tend to be
geographically large states
so that students um would have another
opportunity second um looking at the
past is only going to be partially
helpful in looking toward the future
because there are all kinds of
predictions and I think at least a lot
of them are going to be true that this
pandemic has really um the the good side
of it as it were is that it's increased
capacity and in many places confidence
in distance learning so um so you know
we'll stick with nursing as an example
example if you were in Florida in the
past you would have said we need more
nurses we'll have the two-year colleges
they can't give all four-year degrees
but we'll let them give nursing degrees
now it's possible that the four-year um
institutions can take over through
distance learning so you've got another
Choice I'm not saying one is better than
the other but there are more choices now
because of the distance head the other
thing is that New Hampshire has and Joe
may have cited the number but it's going
to be high people with some college but
no degree and um and that's another you
know idea to think about as you think
about what do you want from a new
Arrangement is um greater success that
can be a hard group to reenroll because
in many cases they left because it
wasn't working for them um and so
bringing them back is not always an easy
thing but it's another way to boost the
educational level of a state is to is to
have th many of those people come back
and earn a
degree thank you so uh have you have you
seen any locations where they've had to
close a campus I've read literature
where we're going to see in the next few
years 25% of our colleges going out of
business in the country um in most cases
people are talking about independent
institutions um so you can merge and
close and and there was an announcement
in The Chronicle of Higher Ed um this
week about a new Trans transformational
part ship fund I should remember the
name on it because I'm I'm on their
academic Advisory Group and it's the
idea is to make um grants up to
$100,000 available to institutions that
serve high need students to talk about
forms of partnership so that's something
that you might want to look at as well
um they're very interested in supporting
um uh students of color but also
institutions that have high levels of um
students with financial need generally
students with pel grants
um it's you know closing closing a
public institution of higher education I
am struggling to think of that
happening um in Vermont you know there
was a proposal to do that and now they
have a different Chancellor and had one
within 10 days I believe um it it's just
really hard in Maine their smallest
campus was at Machias and it was
um approaching unsustainable ility the
enrollment had fallen off I think
they're down to about 700 students right
now and so what they did was make it a I
forget the term they use but essentially
a branch Campus of the
flagship um and so you know Solutions
differ that they're looking for that
merger in Vermont there's going to be
con I mentioned Connecticut there are
going to be more things going on and the
the geography and the character um are
are different in every state but you
know I think it's a it's an argument
for looking ahead as well as learning
from what people have done in the past
because looking ahead is going to be
different demographically and
technologically it's also going to be
different because there are things like
you know Google and some other of the
big firms are coming out with these
short-term credentials um I think it
would be wise for institutions to
incorporate those in degrees for for
people who have them and um because the
because the degree will go beyond the
work force employment you know you want
your degrees to improve Civic life and
cultural life in the state and and as
well as the economic life for
people certificate's not going to do
much for your cultural life thank you
represent luno thank thanks Rick um and
um and so so obviously there's there's a
couple of levels of I guess urgency here
there's there's urgency with respect to
the um the community college system
system and the university system in in
addressing this you know sort certainly
along the lines of what um of what um um
chair Marone talked about earlier this
week but there's also you know an
urgency at the legislative um in the
legislature because it's budget writing
time right and and the question is you
know what you know what what
accommodations would need to be put into
the budget um in order to support um
whether it's a study or whether it's
actual implementation of a of a merge
but um in your experience and and maybe
some of the the examples you've talked
about might help shed some light on this
but but what does the you know when you
when when merging um systems like this
um what is the sort of the cash flow
what does the cash flow look like
related to the merger effort well again
I yeah I'm not sure I'm going to be able
to give you a very good answer there but
I I would incer encourage you to think
about whether you do it from All I'm
gonna I'm going to change my verb tense
and assume you are going to do something
here okay um whether you do it now or
whether you have a whether you make a
commitment to do it and set a date out
there in the meantime X will happen
these if these two systems are going to
come together again they're going to
need some support for integrated
technology and they're going to need
some outside advice they're going to
need you know the people who are there
at the institutions and at the system
office are trust me fully engaged now
given everything that's going on and
next year probably won't be as
disruptive as this year but it's going
to be a hard year in many ways so some
out some extra help for the people who
are there maybe over Summers and
bringing in some help for people I think
it's going to be an efficiency move um
in the long run and an effectiv and move
because you want it if you're going to
do this you want it to go well and if it
takes a little extra money to help help
it go well and that reflects your
confidence in people to make it go well
and your and your um statement of
support for the importance of public
higher education for New Hampshire then
you know I would encourage you to do
that so so um when when you're talking
about a little extra money though I mean
is that like in the context of of the um
the both both systems you know operating
budgets operating budgets um you know
maybe you up some kind of group that has
an official charge and you give them
some support so that they can help
figure out um you know what exactly what
is needed I I would encourage you to to
talk to um Vermont Sophie zne um who is
the interim CH I think she's inter
anyway she's effectively the chancellor
now of the three St and ask her how'
they figure this out and there's a a
legislative committee and Jim paage is
working with them and has worked with
Sophie and talked to them about how did
they figure out how much this was going
to cost and it's not it's not the same
problem but it's a similar State and a a
Now
problem great great thanks very much
Barbara Rick you're muted yeah Dr britam
I'd like to follow up on what representa
luno was you know
discussing um so in the next
year or so would it be wise for us to
establish uh from uh
membership on the trustees of the
University system membership from the uh
Community College a coordinating Council
of sorts to come out and we're we're
find we're we're identifying a lot of
different considerations and questions
associated with the merger everything
from accreditation to transfer credits
to fiscal management Etc um governance
uh so a coordinating Council
working with the legislature um or at
least coordinating with the legislature
we do have a higher education study
committee established in the rsas
currently and so coming out and trying
to identify some of the issues and pro
propose various
resolutions prior to are actually
getting into the merger and in the short
term maintain funding independently for
for the community college and for the
University system I guess I'm looking at
slowing it down a little bit um could
you respond to any of that please well
you know the more I listen to you and
think about this I think slowing it down
a little bit and you know if you slow
down a little bit you can increase your
probability of getting it right um this
is a big step um and I think having a
designated group with some some people
from the two um boards but think about
are there one or two or three other
people you want in there also so it's
not again it's that fiduciary and not
just you know representative idea um and
you would know who they are or you could
you can have help figuring out who they
are but um somebody it might be somebody
from out of state even but somebody who
could come in and help them think about
forward not just understanding who we
are now we need to understand who we are
now but we need also need to think about
where is it we want to be and how can we
come back with a proposal that gives us
the best shot at getting
there thank
you yes representative Ford yeah thank
you Mr chairman uh Dr bringham I was
wondering about the possibility in this
since we have a lot of pressure on one
side from move ahead move ahead and a
lot of pressure from the other side to
don't change anything of maybe
floating a partial exercise which is an
intermediate objective in all of this
which is transferability of credits and
before talking to anybody about anything
else say we would like all of them to
begin to communicate about how they can
make their courses transferable among
them and it turned out at least in
Massachusetts to be really a sit down at
the table kind of thing what do you call
and we work by course descriptions yeah
and basically it was hammered out but it
gives something to say you're moving
ahead on and get moving people in unison
without having to really spend any money
it's just done in committees and I just
wondered if that made sense to you well
that can certainly go forward and I
think um you know it's um again it's not
an easy issue um I you could have two
things going on one one a committee and
the other your clear message Mage about
start working on transfer right now um
sometimes it's not course by course um I
was a dean at the University of Rhode
Island and we had a transfer agreement
with the Community College of Rhode
Island and what we found was that you
know if we were looking at six courses
we didn't we didn't carve up the same
subject matter in the same way and
rather than rewrite all those courses
what we did was take a block of them you
know if you took this six we'd count
them as that six and so there's there's
more than one way to do it is that I
have to ask is that MO antlers on your
wall there uh elk it's an elk it's an
elk thank I'm sorry I didn't mean it to
be a distraction no no that's okay if
you look the other way you see the
inflatable children's house where they
bounce in so okay all right he shot that
elk when he was down at UMass L working
in that
institution RI Rick I got a question uh
doctor you you mentioned earlier on your
uh
first part of your presentation about
accreditation can you explain exactly
how does that work from a standpoint on
a campus by campus basis so in essence
if if we were to merge this
institution how are these campuses
individually accredited is is there a
universal accreditation exactly how does
that work great question so it part of
it comes back to how The Higher
Education Act is written because again
of this link to Federal financial aid
and so right now as of June one of the
my last Commission meeting before I
retired the commission approved that
they would accredit the University of
Maine system and and no longer the
individual institutions and they did
that because the University of Maine um
the the UN the separate institutions and
the system and certainly the governing
board wanted more academic sharing than
the commission than the accreditation
process could could accomplish so if
you've got you know Keen State and
Plymouth State doing a a degree program
together accreditation can handle that
if you've got Granite State and the
university doing one the university can
handle that but if they if Maine was
going to be as successful as they wanted
to be then when the accreditation team
showed up everything was going to be so
mixed up that they couldn't figure out
who to hold accountable for the quality
of the academic program and that's
ultimately why they decided to go for um
for accreditation of the system but we
had to go to the Department of Education
and we hired one lawyer instead of two
because we wanted only one opinion we
didn't want two opinions we had get if
we had two lawyers or three opinions um
we hired a lawyer together to see if the
way the law was written for the
University of Maine system if it could
count as quote an institution of higher
education in The Higher Education Act
and the lawyer said yes and the
department said yes and so with that in
mind then the accreditor Nei and and the
system could go ahead together toward
that process I think it will it's it's
not a it's not a solution for everyone
um but for Maine I think it's a good
solution but in our state in New
Hampshire each of the individual states
uh institutions are now accredited 11 of
them are separately accredited correct
really yep so that would that would be a
that would be one of the issues that
would have to be addressed in if if
these campuses were emerge then right so
you you know I mean you yes and there
are possibilities there and again that's
the you know stay in touch with your
creditor advice and if you come up with
an idea or if you set up a committee and
the committee comes up with an idea and
they think well we would like to do it
we'd like to have one system I'm making
this up and I usually make up ridiculous
examples but I can't think of anything
totally ridiculous at this moment so we
want the 11 we want the seven community
colleges accredited as one and we want
the four-year institutions accredited by
want I don't think that's a very good
idea by the way for other reasons but if
that's what they wanted to know would
the commission approve that that's when
they could go in with an advisory
opinion and say here's what we would
like to do here's some you know 20 pages
of Pros about why we think it's a good
idea and how it would work send it in
the staff our corporate motto was weere
a draft of anything they would take it
to a commission meeting if if the answer
wasn't obvious they'd take it to a
commission meeting and the commission
would come back and say no you can't do
it because of X or yes you can do it or
um or we don't quite understand this
part over here or you can do it if you
do
L thank you uh uh Mike I'd like to just
follow up on one thing that uh
representative Myer had and then get to
you in a second but uh doctor in terms
of accrediting let's take for example
Keen state
um are we talking about accrediting Keen
state are we talking about accrediting a
program such as nursing with in Keen
State could you get some clarification
for me please sure sure so what nii does
is accredit Keen State there are nursing
accredit there are specialized
accreditors in various areas so the law
school at the University of New
Hampshire for example is accredited by
the ABA in nursing there are I think now
three accreditors because they don't
agree with each other on how it's done
but your nursing um programs are
accredited by a nursing accreditor and
again um in the case of nursing um and
the case of law they are recognized by
the federal government um if they any
accreditor that's a gatekeeper your
business programs are not they're not
Gatekeepers to to Fe to federal funds of
any kind so and there are three
different um business accreditors and
they all operate separately if you go if
you want to read about specialized
accreditation I would say the best place
to go is ch.org c h ea.org
um and they'll lay all that out thank
you so if uh Kean loses their nursing
accreditation from the nursing program
that's accrediting them yeah do does Nei
get involved with that at all Yes um so
you know that would obviously put
students at risk and so um ne's concern
would be what are you going to do to
protect the student
um do you plan to U we have there's a a
system where they would know where nii
would know that that happened so Nei
would be in touch with Keen State and
say you know how are you protecting the
students are you can you arrange for
them to transfer someplace sometimes
specialized accreditors will say you
lose it at the end of that you know if
they come in October and make a decision
you've lost it in May so that you're not
you know you're not disrupting the
current students um that the program
would be accredited until they graduate
if they're seniors but ne's concern is
um what are you doing to protect
students are you planning to fix the
problems and go back and then depending
on what the problems are sometimes it's
a question of is the problem here a
general problem so again I'm going to
try to make up an example here on the
Fly um nursing lost its accreditation
because the library is locked and they
don't have electronic access and so
nursing students can't get Library
materials um that's obviously a
that the nursing accreditors found it
but it's obviously a problem that would
affect all the students at Keen State
sorry we're picking on Keen
state so in followup just on this this
topic so then we're talking about the
system as it exists right now currently
what happens if we decide we're going to
have our nursing program as part of the
overarching whole
umbrella uh new trustee system and so
we're talking about now getting our
nursing program for ke un for Plymouth
state for all the community colleges
accredited as a one program is that
possible and are there any institutions
doing this the simple answer is I'm not
aware of anybody doing it B it
unfortunately depends on the accreditor
um so there may be accreditors out there
who would do that but I'm sure not all
of them would and I can't speak for the
nursing creditors
thank you represent Moffett yeah yeah
thank you um I'm a history guy but if I
was to quantify this it would start off
with an equation 7 + 4 = 11 which is
pretty simple but uh then as we keep
working this equation that gets bigger
and bigger and there variables anyway I
want to bring up one variable that we
haven't touched on and and I I don't
know if you have any thoughts on this
but Washington
DC uh I think is will be a variable in
this this equation and some fashion I
don't know what but I'm looking at the
several people last year ran for
president on a platform that included
free Community College tuition I'm
looking at the president's comprehensive
plan here real quick says providing two
years of community college or other
highquality training programs tuition
free making public colleges universities
tuition free for all families who earn
under
$125,000 of increased funding for p
grants so anyway I uh do you have any
sense of what might flow from Washington
I know there's there there's a new
cabinet official there I any thoughts or
yeah um again well um uh Larry scha my
successor meets with the other Regional
creditors and they collectively hire um
the term is lobbyists they they I worked
with them for years they're fabulous and
they connect regional accreditation with
what's going on in Washington so that
would be one way to find out the Higher
Education Act will was last reauthorized
in 2008 I think it was and they're
supposed to do it every five years so
they're they're running just a little
bit behind on that um the projections
last I heard nobody was hyper optimistic
that they'll get it done now but it's
possible they would take an idea like
that and write it into the higher ed act
or they might do it separately um as a
separate law I I I don't really know you
know so for for our planning purposes
probably need to be careful about
assuming uh too much out of uh
Washington I I'm thinking yeah
yeah
uh uh doctor we have uh a number of
non-traditional students who attend our
community college system older students
than the university system which caters
more to the one the recent
graduate um have you seen in any of the
other mer mergers throughout New England
or the country where there has been a
negative impact to the cost that this
non-traditional student has been able to
get into the community college for
either a certificate or a two-year
degree at a very uh uh a lessened cost
than you would for a four-year degree
have you seen any negative results that
due to a merger there's been fewer
non-traditional students participating
in in postc we have 65 25 65 65 25 uh
we're trying to get you know by 2025 65%
of our kids with a working skill or a
two or foure degree uh I don't want to
see that you know uh hurt um and lose
our non-traditional students uh so do do
we see that the Community College tends
to um lose traditional students due to
maybe the costs for that tuition
increasing at the community college
level when you have a merger another
good question Mims again would be in a
better position than I am to answer the
question I will say that um Connecticut
in I think it was
2011 com put its two-year institutions
and it's foure not not not the flagship
but the the regional campuses the
four-year um state universities into a
single system along with Charter Oak
which is roughly analogous to Granite
State so it's one system and I do know
that the enrollment at the community
colleges has gone down I don't know if
that's the reason I I wouldn't you know
but again that's another group that you
might want to be in contact with and see
if you know see if in Connecticut people
think that that was part of what
happened thank you hey Rick can I ask a
question along those lines sure what so
you brought up 65 by 25 which is which
is obviously been an initiative uh here
in New Hampshire but across the country
at different um
you know proportions and and and time
frames um in every state but um but you
know one of the things I learned
recently at an nhti which is the
community college in conquered um at an
Advisory board meeting was that um um
65% of their prospective students are
looking for not necessarily for two-year
degrees but for high value um
certificates and um um so that they can
go right into the workforce and so you
know given given that should should the
should the state also be looking at
possibly re-evaluating the the 65 by 25
um goal and whether that just applies to
twoyear and four-year degrees or does it
expand beyond that yeah I think that's a
little above my pay grade I don't know
um uh that's a good question I'm not
sure I have much to contribute there you
know I will say that um given the rise
of distance learning and given what
institutions and faculty you know
faculty from all reports I've heard
around the country did a you know HED is
not known for changing quickly um all
the time and um but the general reports
that I've heard about faculty stepping
up to the plate and offering programs
through distance learning has been
terrific some of them even love it you
know and um so going forward that's
going to be different and I think um
it's related to the transfer issue
making those certificates avail able but
thinking systematically about how can we
make sure that that lets the student
leave with a pathway toward a degree
whether that's a two-year degree or a
four-year degree and looking again and
this is be a fresh opportunity to look
again at the line between the credit and
non-credit things that students do um
you know at some community colleges and
I can't speak to any of yours about this
the you know they're very responsive to
the local employers and come up with um
certificates that are are noncredit in
areas where maybe some other community
colleges have degree programs there we
did a study um Nei did a study about
three years ago and I guess they're
repeating it where we looked at
institutions that had low graduation
rates and we wrote to them and said you
know this is the information we have we
want seven pages please I used to teach
seventh grade so I know the answer to
the book report question how long should
it be we want seven pages of do we have
the right numbers what else do you know
about retention graduation and transfer
what are you doing about it and what do
you know about how successful it is and
what are you planning to do in the
future and we got back they weren't all
uniformally good we got some back that
were wonderful and the one that sticks
in my mind was um Community College I
don't remember which one it was that
said we have a program for welders and
um when welders go out for their you
know internship or whatever they call it
the the good ones get hired and so they
leave without a degree and that it's an
important program here it depresses our
graduation rate so what we did was look
at what were the credits that the
welders were likely welding students
were likely not to have when they went
out on that internship we contacted them
we said we're going to offer them at
night you know we're gonna probably now
we're gonna offer them online because we
want you to finish that degree because
some of those welders are going to want
to own their own welding companies and
they're going to want a business degree
or at least some business credits along
the way and so finding ways to help
people Move Along come back you know
there all kinds of predictions I'm sure
you've seen them that you know it used
to be oneand done that's those days are
gone people are going to be coming back
and back and and I think two and foure
institutions need to take keep that in
mind okay great thank you thank you Rick
yes one yeah one of the one of the
questions that I have is that with the
particularly in this state as it relates
to the cost of higher education and I
think think a lot of families are
looking at what's the ROI what's the
return on investment of having my child
go to a fouryear school when they might
be able to go to a community college
particularly if they're interested in
let's say computer programming and they
can go to a community college and get a
Microsoft certificate and leave with
that certificate and start at the at the
$70,000 $80,000 level unlike if my child
wanted to be a teacher and went to four
years and came out and would start at
like
35,000 doll yeah so I think the concern
that I have is that how do we um
ensure that there are opportunities for
people to have a variety of different
opportunities to get their education and
be successful at it and not be assumed
by the need for to go to a fouryear
institution is that's the way you have
to go yeah and I that's one of the
things I've learned and become very
respectful of the community college
program uh and the opportunity for
students who have limited resources or
who may have a particular interest that
they want to pursu but don't necessarily
have to have a quote liberal arts degree
I don't even know what a liberal arts
degree is going to get you these days
but uh any thoughts on that well first
of all I majored in English and history
so um I used to advise un cited students
at the University of Rhode Island I
remember one came in I'd like to have a
major in English but I don't know what I
could do with it and I said I was a dean
at the time I said you can have my job
okay so um I I think um more and more we
don't know where those degrees are going
to take people and where their careers
are going to go used to be you know one
got on a line and stayed on it and that
and that's happening less and less so
you know all kinds of messages and
opportunities for students to keep their
options open you this is what you want
to do now but you don't know where
that's going to take you and you you we
we've done everything we can and but we
need you the student as a partner to
keep those options open um get yourself
situated right now but think about you
know you're probably not going to do
that forever
so make it so that you can go on and do
the next thing and we're there for
you yeah doctor the the we we've got
ourselves really in a corner here in the
state as well as I think Vermont does
probably more so here in terms of our
kids are coming out with very high debt
tuition costs are like second highest in
the Public's in the
country and and we're we're we're seeing
our our tuition costs undercut by Orono
and by UMass L and out of state uh which
they're attracting our students so we we
are at a situation where our revenues
are declining
due to uh this unless we do what Vermont
did and start chasing these out of state
students but now they've got themselves
at the point where uh their Flagship has
what 75 80% out of Staters and the
remaining are are inate and we
definitely don't want that but we're
quickly changing I think it used to be
pretty like 60% inate 40% out of state
now it's almost
reversed in New
Hampshire so we we have this problem how
do we compete now with places like
Massachusetts which are really going
after our students there's a limited
pool oroa is just dragging them out of
this state right now how do we resolve
this issue if we don't do a
merger uh it's a good question I do
think a merger would probably put you in
a better position to address it
collectively um but but it's a hard
problem and it's certainly related to
what Joe was talking about um I
remember you know I can see um
university of main Oro signs I think I
saw one over near the other day you know
um it was a great idea Flagship match
why not um I think you know one thing to
look at is and this kind of relates to
some of our other conversation one of
the programs that the federal government
funds is a work study program and um uh
it provide it it's not well enough
funded you could talk to your people in
Washington about increasing the fun
there but the federal government pays I
think 80% of what students earn they
work on campus some of them work in the
community but most of them work on
campus and part of what that does is
help Bond them to the campus it lets it
helps them get to know um some of the
people who work at the institution I
remember again at the University of
Rhode Island it was the people we had a
physical education program and the
people in the athletic store room some
of the students who were struggling got
to know those people who worked in in
the store room and they were the adult
that they connected with and so looking
for ways to you know help the student
make that connection with the university
which is probably harder um with online
than it is otherwise or with the
community college but you know part of
the community look for ways to um do
that I think is
important thank you very much do because
if they if they're gonna work and they
go off campus to work that makes their
life harder if you can figure out ways
to have more of them working on campus
that I think will help
thank you are there further uh questions
from the Comm we've had Dr brittenham
here now for an hour and 15 minutes and
and uh I know that we had indicated
initially about an hour for her and I
hope we're not grilling you too much not
at all not at all um are there are there
further questions from the
committee well Dr britam I really
appreciate your your um your your
presenting to us today and
offering us uh so much to think about
and and giving us some advice is where
we can go get some of these answers are
are there is there anything in summary
you'd like to say to the committee uh
before we move on here I think New
Hampshire is fortunate to have uh you
all working on this problem and thinking
about it you've got good expertise that
you've thrown into the conversation and
a good commitment and you uh understand
how difficult this is um I appreciate
the opportunity to be with you I'm going
to sign off here and go back can listen
to you on the public part um again for
as long as I can today and if I can be
helpful to you in any way going forward
please let me know thank you very much
Dr thank you very much great thank
you thank you
again okay for the committee right now
what we ought to do is
that take about a five or 10 minute
break and then uh come back and then uh
uh discuss where we're going to go uh on
trying to put together some you know
some considerations here I did have a
chance to talk with uh uh represent
umberger in division two this
morning and um she's indicating that
they are um they're looking at possibly
saying slow down uh on on this process
um and and working with the the systems
in trying to develop some process to do
that I also offered tour her the RSA
that we have the higher education study
committee already on the books that
should be engaged at at this time on
this topic and and she she uh uh
listened and wrote down
187-a uh call
28 so um I think they're they're very
much aware uh and as she alluded to me
today it things are changing by the hour
in terms of you know how to address this
um within Finance so um I I don't think
they come up with any recommendations
yet it hasn't gone to the whole finance
committee but she has to have her report
ready to go next week so we are going to
have to come up with something this
afternoon whether we incorporate the the
the sheet that you and and uh Mel you
and Dave put together and of course I
put together a sheet also uh I think
there's a lot of duplicity between the
two there is uh and uh so what I'd like
to do is just take a short break and
then um come back here discuss that a
little bit and then we're GNA probably
have to break for a lunch and and then
come back and work a little bit
here you want to break till 11:30
Rick yeah yeah we'll break for 11:30 and
then we'll come back and discuss our our
our route we're going to take the path
we're going to take here then we'll
probably have another break for lunch
and then and then return so let's come
back at 11:30 everybody hit the
refrigerator for a second or two all
right
thanks
see
it's
for
[Music]
oh
you
are we all
back yeah I think
so one two three four five six
yep well folks
uh we've heard now from Dr McKay and
we've heard um uh then from the Dr Don
Burks and Susan Huard Joe Moran and
Katherine F Venture and today
from um Dr
brittenham and we've been very fortunate
to have some very experienced
professionals provided advice now I I
we're at the position
where we have to issue some kind of a
brief to the division two and talking
with
uh uh Karen umberger uh representative
umberger
uh she she needs she does need that
right off immediately seeing that
they're they're moving forward and
they've got to make a recommendation so
uh I think our policy input is is
necessary and critical to this process
so uh I I would U then suggest that we
uh take the remaining part of the time
which we're going to have today and I
you know it's starting from this point
forward and and looking at um what we've
heard
and in the reports that we've got
several draft uh suggestions here in
front of us uh maybe what we ought to do
is Wade through this um line you know
issue by issue and resolve is you know
is this a element that we need to put
forward to division two for their
consideration um uh let's just have an
open discussion right now and and folks
that would like to you know before we
get into to it are there any other
suggestions as to a direction that we
might want to uh consider um
representative Ellison uh Rick just a
question to you I think which is have
you have you thought about format I mean
how how this thing might what this thing
might look like and sending it over or
we want to talk about that I mean I you
might have some thoughts about how to do
that yeah I I'd love to have a format
which is more TR
as we've done for so many commissions
and reports when we send it back to
either the speaker or the president of
the senate or to the state librarian Etc
however we just don't have that time
today to to go through that and involve
our
researcher um to uh provide us you know
some review or a summary reports of what
we have have heard in testimony we
definitely should be uh in our report
including the names of those who
testified and the sources of information
that we received that should be an
addendum to the report um but uh I I
think that our you know the we would
start off the report I would assume with
our task and our task I think can to be
defined in a couple quick quick
sentences much like that you know I had
you know as the purpose of this uh
subcommittee when we started and it
reads to to consider and identify
relevant information per pertaining to
the New Hampshire college and university
a system as proposed in hb2 uh pursuant
to you know in the chapter of of
law uh then we go down we start listing
some of the the the facts that we've
identified represent Miler yeah I think
I think one of the I think both the U
the questions that David and I uh put
together yesterday and your questions
Rick I think there's a lot of similarity
there I think the threshold question for
me is what we've heard from our various
input
individuals is whether or not through
the budget as currently
proposed this merger should take
place and I think um based upon your
conversations with representative
umberger
and frankly my concern is that there are
a lot of complex issues here of which
we've identified in those
questions that need to be dealt
with uh prior to moving forward with the
budget
proposal that division two is currently
considering uh and that's why I think at
least in in the notes that I sent to you
ear yesterday
afternoon the up to the formation of
some kind kind of a group a
representative group that can do some of
this planning and some of this answering
some of these
questions prior
to um moving forward uh with a with a
merger should that be the recommendation
of the final study and I just I just
think this is such a an important issue
I I recognize and I understand and I
feel the
urgency and I that was very impactful on
me yesterday but on the other hand I I
just I just think there there is a need
to slow this down to look at it with a
time frame of coming up with with a
conclusion so I don't see this going on
odd
infinitum but I think that what we have
what I have sensed in the data we've
gathered here is that there are a
tremendous amount of issues that need to
be at least looked at prior to trying to
create this entity
that would bring these campuses all
together into one system so that so I
think there's a threshold question Rick
I think do we
conclude that some time needs to take
place to do with these questions rather
than moving forward uh with it in the
budget I think that's a fundamental
question for this group to deal with as
we uh make some recommendations or some
raise some issues with the uh division
two well I I in response that um I think
we can all concur that the process needs
to slow
down um now issues associated with the
budget we do have division two and
finance which are going to have to make
the decision regarding budget whether
that moves forward I I we were tasked to
try to provide the information that we
can locate and discover that either
either you know the supports both ways
uh I I think we just got to be uh
providing that information so I do not
want to say U uh and present the the the
U the the position that uh we either
support or don't support the merger I I
I I think that we can't do that seeing
that obviously we haven't had a thorough
enough discussion on that uh there are a
lot of other people that have provided
us email corresponden uh I just saw
something that came in from Steve
Rosenberg um regarding his perceptions
and understandings of how this might you
know impact um Career Technical
education uh issues as associated with
the community college system and as he
he as a u a trustee or a board member in
the community college
system and there are others as well
um I'm I'm not totally 100% familiar
with some of the financial issues that
you know Finance is going to have to
deal with in terms of you know the
revenues and expenses of the community
college system I do know though that uh
they're at critical mass in turn in
terms of there is no margin anymore for
you know making this come out even we're
not coming out even with operating our
our postsecondary education
institutions um and that's something
that going to have to be decided by
division two and by so you're you're
suggesting basically that the the
questions or the issues that that we've
posed in the questions that on on both
that have been submitted to this
subcommittee that we basically say here
are the questions that we came up with
forward that to the division two and
then based upon uh the the questions
that we're putting forward let them make
they've got to make that decision
ultimately what to do with the but is
that what you're saying well I'm I'm
trying to say that I believe we have two
very very strong Educational Systems for
postsecondary Ed the community college
system and the university system are
very effective in fact we we're putting
out students which have skills which
come out with degrees which are valued
and and we've been successful we want to
see that Contin so the bottom line is I
do not want to you
know I don't want to destroy all the
good things that we've done and say well
no we gotta just jump ship and do
something else here uh we want to better
our system and all the considerations
and questions that we have listed you
know I'm looking
at one I have yes there's duplicity but
there's 43 considerations and questions
there and the one that I received from
uh you were you know there's another 26
there some are are similar but all that
we're not going to resolve those in one
quick uh period of time there we all
recognize it's going to be an extended
time frame to really put this place in
effect and make sure we're doing what
our that objective is that goal is but
uh there's a lot of issues associated
with reaching a university system that
is one um
and to do that um we need to have all
these issues looked at thoroughly and I
believe that by slowing down in the next
year these questions these
considerations should be given to that
group and that and and and listening to
what Dr britam just said we want to have
folks there that have the content and
and the understandings and the fiduciary
respon possibilities and understandings
to make some of these decisions um so I
would suggest that we we if we're going
to recommend anything that we slow down
we offer these considerations and
questions but we also suggest that a
coordinating Council of some type be
developed to address these issues and
these
considerations um uh and then leaving
the decision what to do with hb2 to
finance people and we'll obviously have
a opportunity on the house floor to you
know address things there but I we do
need to have our questions and
considerations addressed and so I would
say a coordinating Council made up of
people that come from both systems and
maybe as Dr britam said you may want to
have three other people are so in there
which have expertise to work with that
Council this way it wouldn't be a
commission where you have to get
something through legislation right it
be a recommendation that it be picked up
right now and start
working yeah Dave yeah so Rick I I um I
absolutely concur with u with with I
think what what what appears to be um
you know consensus on the um on the slow
it down um a bit uh I I think in in use
in taking um Dr brittingham's word slow
it down get it right there's some
cautionary tales out there I think we
saw that in the enms um report as well
right um and and so I think that's an
important um uh piece of this I um I and
I I think we're we're probably talking
about the same thing but but um but I
think we got to work out you know what
sort of details we might want to
recommend in terms of whether it's a
council or a merger commission or or
whatever that goes in and and um you
know is is is charged with with with
certain tasks and maybe goes after that
that group of 50 questions that that are
on you know your sheet and Mel's um you
know sheet from from from yesterday and
and I'm sure they'll come up with more
more things too but um but I I I guess
you know we we we had a we had a really
good conversation with Dr brittingham
about um about the trustees and about a
um you know whether it's a councel or
commission or or something like that and
um and it it wasn't clear to me as to
whether or not I mean when she's talking
about the trustees who are the two
boards that are currently in place to
manage the university system not man AG
but but oversee the university system
oversee the community college system
they're the ones that have the fiduciary
responsibilities um a new a new
unified um um Board of Trustees I think
she was talking about having obviously
fiduciary responsibilities but that
would be sort of a post merger type of
thing in a in a in a council or or a
commission to look into the merger I
don't think we're talking about fiducial
responsibilities um U at this point I
think we're talking about people that
have it doesn't necessarily have to be
created by the legislature but but
people like like you know us that have
that have been interested in this area
but also other you know um members of
the public um possibly members of of the
of the system boards um um but but
certainly you know the most important
thing is who we hear from who that
commission or that Council would be
hearing from yeah I I Dave I I concur
that we need to have people on there
that have some definitely have the
knowledge and the understandings of what
what this whole uh bill is about there
are folks such as for example Dr Burks
who who testified and and and who has uh
experienced um you mergers and worked in
different systems and is uh bringing
Innovation to the the institution which
he's in charge of um I think that taking
that type of individual and putting them
onto a council um and uh I I feel also
that this is something which is I don't
want to get down and start micromanaging
something which I don't really have all
the policies and all the
consideration but for the people that
are living it and breathing it and
managing it I think it's
responsibility that should be put back
on those folks and I Rely heavily on the
Joe morans of the world or the Catherine
provines or the Susan hu's of the world
absolutely and and and have them come
out with a working Council to structure
this but I also feel that there should
be some kind of uh if you're looking at
a flight path from here to there where
we want to be there's going to be
benchmarks along the way yeah reporting
periods where there's performance
measures which there has to be a report
back to the legislative oversight or
study educate you know some committee
that we have to ensure that there's um
communication going on with the
legislature that is what we are
responsible for under
187a and and um I think that we need to
really have that
communication
right um ju just to clarify Rick um I I
I agree with all of that um and I think
we're talking about the same thing that
this coordinating council is not a an
oversight Council it's not a
fiduciary doesn't fiduciary
responsibilities to either system it's
it's clearly just an it's an it's a
investigation
it's doing what we have been trying to
do and and uh and and finalizing it and
giving some sense of direction of of
timeline of of uh uh how we're going to
be handling all these issues that we've
addressed yeah I think I think the one
thing that that Dr britam said this
morning that I thought was good is is to
assess what is but more important what
could
be and it's that it's that future issue
yeah with with a foundation of what is
that I think that a combination of that
conversation that that I get can get
excited about about the future
so I I see that uh representative moffs
had his hand up
politely
excuse uh real quick been mentioned a
couple times we have duplicity I think
we mean duplication
no duplicity around here right so
anyway Dave may have been TR with Dave
became on the board at NTI but 1995
Governor Merill uh asked the Comm or at
the time was the technical col system to
completely restructure and president's
were L very painful uh some good came
from that I think there was some some
savings that were identified by
necessity but very painful I think there
might be some lessons uh we could
hearken back to from 199 95 good and bad
um other college experiences I mean
Vermont Maine Connecticut on and on uh
we've already looked at some of their
issues of course we're unique but I
think there are some common rer issues
that we can uh identify and look at and
apply to our
situation um one one quick question one
more comment um executive Council
approval is that would the chancellor be
subject to EC approval at some point or
not you know you're asking a question uh
Mike that I can't answer you on that
yeah I I just it just occurred to me my
my last uh quick comment is just
procedural um in terms of what we do
next uh I have all kinds of notes I know
you all do as well um if there was some
sort of a working document that that uh
we once uh Rea Jennifer whoever get
something started to put together uh for
for us to be able to see that working
document and then respond to that might
be useful when what is Karen's deadline
R when when do you need to submit
something the the the deadline that
Karen told me this morning for this
report is this
afternoon so so Rick yeah Al along those
lines and and I think what what what
Mike's talking about is real important
here and you started out talking about
the um uh the sort of the framing up
this document with with who we've heard
from I think that's you know summarizing
who we've heard from extract from that
findings and then develop from that a a
recom
recommendations that that's correct yeah
okay yeah
yeah also we can also use remarks which
have you know if we've received written
you know information we should be we
should be looking at everything we can
um and uh because we're actually not
trying to take a position we're just
trying to provide a brief which has
these identified
considerations that we're hoping that
will be listened to and taken into
account when action is taken on
hb2 Mr chairman yeah uh I'm wondering if
a starting point might be in the AGB
form that says suggest and
recommendations for Governors and
legislators because it starts off with a
send a clear signal that Merit comes
first in recruiting screening appointing
public highered governing board
members I mean that kind of a thing at
least they they take they set a very
high bar in all that I realize that but
I think at least that they lay out
personal experience professional
experience commitment and that's an
important part of it I mean you're
asking a lot of people well the
governance of how this all works is is
is huge and well beyond our domain right
now yeah uh it's it's just like the
question I posed to Katherine this
morning you're going to have the the
this new board and then underneath that
new board and reporting that board will
be a
Chancellor and then you're going to have
the college presidents under neath the
chancellor now the question I had though
are are the the the president's going to
report
to some other structure or is the
chancellor going to have the
authority is the chancellor going to
have the authority to and even the time
or the capability to evaluate and and
and get on top of all 11 institutional
leaders or do we need a vice chair and
and during some kind kind of a
transitional mode here does the vice
chair then have more uh association with
uh the the community college system and
that can also then be the one that may
uh assess the institutional presidents
uh and and have those reporting and then
the vice chair reports to the chair or
Chancellor um there's going to have to
be a whole new arrangement of
administration in that office the
Chancellor's office um that's to be
decided I think that's where this this
coordinating Council exactly exactly
into play we can't make that
determination we don't have it no yeah
no I agree with what you're saying about
that though I do think that having a CEO
is absolutely essential I've been in
that position several times from below
that and mid management gets absolutely
crushed that whole process if you don't
have a boss who can say Okay break apart
we're doing this somebody has to be able
to make a decision and if they they
can't make that decision or they're
precluded we can have Vice chancellors
or whatever that that's all just a
mechanism for making it work but
somebody's got to be in charge yeah
that's that's to be discussed and you
know because we we were we're living
right now with two systems that have
worked but they're totally different
system
in terms of who makes those decisions
and who reports to whom so what I'd like
to do if we
can is um art wants to Art wants to say
something I think oh there's okay yes
art your hands up just quickly I I I
like the idea of framing sort of what
we're going to put together in terms of
findings and recommendations seems to me
that that that helps to focus on the
message whatever it is that we want to
send but I think both of those findings
and recommendations make a whole lot of
sense well yeah but we're gota be very
careful how we word that word
recommendation okay right yeah so
because that was not what we're T to do
we're we're going to provide the
information the considerations those
elements that need more Resolve
right so yeah we we can we can identify
our our our source
and what we've found and what we've
heard um and and like you know just just
like today with Dr britam there is a lot
of good stuff that came from Dr
brittenham uh from that we're going to
then develop questions considerations
and that's what we got to do so I think
that what we need to do is yes we will
summarize the reports of the various
individuals reported yes but then below
that we've got to write down this
section that um well it's partially been
tackled by uh Dave and Mill and myself
with those report we need to walk
through those and just walk through them
and say okay that's that's a good
element that has to be put in here or
it's or it's already identified in that
other element uh so that's where I think
we got to spend our time it'll take you
know some time to go through these
discussions and uh I would suggest that
we take a a quick break for a lunch then
come back and work on this and take you
know we we mentioned earlier we could be
going to 2 o'clock with these sheets in
front of us we may be able to get down
through some of those sheets and say um
you know and get it down quickly I'm
saying by two o'clock three o'clock and
and then having that as a report that's
ready to go forward to Karen so so what
we're talking about is is uh and and Jen
can put this together from a standpoint
of who we talked with that's that's who
are our Consultants that we dealt with
yeah and then and we we have that as the
first part then when we come back after
lunch we can go through the questions I
think both the qu question sheets are
very similar I think your your issues
are a little more detailed than the
questions that we came up with but then
identify are these the questions that we
have are there others that we need to
add yes and then from that that's what
then is submitted uh to uh division two
yes yes that's it I wonder if it's a
good idea to attach any of these other
pre-developed ones like the one in in
the AGB and other organizations and just
reference them yes as sources that that
will occur Oliver what we will do is
that when we have the summary of the
individuals who spoke then we're going
to have all the materials that they you
know and an addendum with all those
materials that have been submitted and
for those that didn't present there's
other materials which we have we can
send a full
package okay and so it'll all be
there I got I gotta jump for a a 12
o'clock but I'll be back at one okay
that's fine is
um H okay uh anybody else have to be is
everybody going to be back and available
at 1 or 12:30 I if if Dave's going to be
gone um 12:30 works for me if you want
to get some stuff done till Dave gets
back is that okay with everybody else I
think that be
here I don't think it'll hurt to start
12:30 and then Dave can cut in on it uh
so let's let's take a break right now
Jen and we will come back and open this
uh subcommittee back up at
12:30 all right
good see you then yeah take care thank
you still there
Jen I am just had to get to my mute
button okay we're gonna take a break
till
12:30 um what we also you You Have you
listened to all our conversations we've
had yes and I'm I'm starting on a draft
for you yeah and when you're talking
about the individuals who spoke if you
can just you know not everything they
said just a an overview a summary of
what they have proposed and and
discussed okay so because it can't be
too lengthy uh seeing that this has to
get out to division two today yeah um do
you w to do you want to summarize it it
seems like almost everyone gave us kind
of a brief um talking points we could
just attach those that might be well I
think what we will do is Summarize each
one of those persons for example like
you know today uh what we had spoken by
Dr Barbara brittenham was issues a so
and I took some notes here um maybe when
we come back at 12:30 we could give you
some you want like two or three
sentences about where they're coming
from for this report because then we can
also list below barbar's name how she
can be contacted you know you know so
that we have that reference and and to
for the committee so for example if
representative umberger had a question
it would be easy to call us or call her
directly okay yeah um I could also you
know I could put together maybe like a
contact list for her that that's right
and it might be yeah that that'd be
wonderful if we could just have a
contact list for that you know folks
that that have you know submitted
materials like Don and Susan and yeah
yeah okay okay I will work on that and
I'll try to get you something that you
can start looking at at 12:30 well
that's just a half hour Jen I I
understand you're you're really well I'm
I'm underway already I'm uh I'm
optimistic okay thank you Jen I won't
delay it anymore then okay okay thanks
uhuh
this is all Bo you
call
am I
speaking oh okay you caught me at the
tail end of our session there and I I
couldn't take the
call
Y
h
for
rck I'm not on any meds that uh that Co
shot really seemed to hit me more than
it hit you you look great but not I'm uh
I'm hanging in there well I'm doing the
same thing Mel I might I M me you know
it's my arm is sorer than sore can be
but it's it's
uh you
know here's here's here's the little
news boys a week after I had my
shot I broke out into a fullbody rash no
don't now now now for me for me that's a
good s sign because it says that my
compromise to immune system is reacting
accordingly so it was good I mean it
wasn't wasn't itchy or anything but it
was
just one one of us one day it was just
bang just like that it was there and it
lasted
for I think about about 10 days I don't
want to hear about that well believe me
it's just uh it's it wasn't it wasn't
inconvenient wasn't painful it was just
wow what's this
so I don't know but it it's it's it's
hurting yeah I skip my morning push-ups
today okay hey guys we got to go ahead
and start here because we are limited
with time I spoke with Jen four here
over the period of the break and she's
working on the top part of the form that
the traditional form we use in in in
reporting uh uh committee commission
type work
um but what we're going to do
now is uh go down through the
considerations and questions that we've
have um and and and go line by line and
see if that's okay and and incorporate
that into the report uh Jennifer has an
appointment at 2:30 today but there's
another person available up there in
research that can help us so let's try
to you know stick with Jen and and try
to you know see if we get down through
these Pages here with these
considerations and remember just and
what she can do is she can modify them
because if they're not grammatically
correct or something like that but um uh
so let's let's start working on that um
does everybody have in front of
them or on their screen the two reports
that we're going to be looking
at yeah I would suggest Rick that we go
through your list first because I think
it's a little more it's more
comprehensive than just a question okay
either way because we yeah we can do
that and then we can go down the other
list too because I want to be fair and
honest and and get down through
everything and incorporate in if we're
missing something yeah all right so the
the the list we're looking at then is
the one that has on the top of it says
education subcommittee Representatives
yeah lists our
names and and then the first
item uh on that underneath
considerations questions number one um I
took that from another report that's
more of a a nationwide I don't know if
it is estimated that 25% of colleges
could go out of business in the next few
years we know that it's going to happen
we were just told by uh Barbara
brittenham that um that's probably a lot
of
privates um
um so in the second part can New
Hampshire's small fouryear school
survive without becoming part of the New
Hampshire postsecondary system including
certificate two-year degree and
four-year degree offerings economy and
scale I don't know if we need that one
there
um it I I'd just like to have up or down
in terms of I go with it I go with the
way you have it rick okay let's let's
just leave number one
in go to number two then is a New
Hampshire student benefiting financially
or losing faith in attending a New
Hampshire postsecondary institution in
which he or she runs up unaffordable
debt and who has has an almost one in
two chance he or she would not graduate
that's dealing with the debt issue yep
good okay anybody oppositional there
that's Nationwide d da number three from
2001 to 2021 postsecondary tuition Rose
over
140% UNH has the second highest tuition
rate among public
universities I think that needs
to just just go ahead art we we don't
need to recognize this is a a work
session thanks I I I think that the
issue about the high second highest
tuition rate's got to be in there
somewhere yeah the the um and I think uh
along with that deals with the question
that britam raised this morning is how
are you going to get more New Hampshire
students to attend New Hampshire higher
education that's I think what you just
said needs to be added in there yeah H
how how are we going to get more kids to
attend when it's so high exactly and I
think that I think I would add that as a
second part of of number three as a
question
uh
Jen yep I think Jen should be in part of
this conversation too she shouldn't be
muted yeah you know she I don't think
she is muted but she's there there you
are good okaycome make a suggestion like
that can you just pencil in yep I don't
think I caught the full question could
you we're on the the the yeah number
three and what we're looking at is UNH
has the second highest tuition rate
among public
universities the next question Mel would
you read how you phrase that I would
just say how how are we going to attract
uh New Hampshire students to New
Hampshire
colleges with such high tuition
rates so that would be that there' be
two sentences in that you don't
necessarily need that 2001 to 2020
postsecondary tuition R over although we
could raise that because that's no I
think that's important I think that's
important yeah okay so we'll just add
that one sentence on the back side of
number three let's go to number four how
does the state anticipate improving
existing credit transfer ability among
institutions given that program
accreditations happens at the individual
department or program level
levels that's a question it's a question
y yeah yeah
is it
legitimate I think so yeah yeah this
came from the alliance yeah it was in
their report okay absolutely okay number
five
then uh hb2 overhauls postsecondary
governance within that organizational
structure what is the specific role of
the chancellor do presidents report to
the chancellor or the board does the
chancellor evaluate
president pres a president president's
performance does the board hire and fire
presidents have job descriptions been
defined Beyond broad statements made in
hb2 page 52 lines 6 through
13 yeah they're all good questions I
think yeah oh yeah very good yeah flag
this a number of times and I we're not
looking to make recommendations um but
we did identify the problem or the
difference disparity between ccsnh with
the
chancellor uh with the president's
answer to the CH Chancellor and usn when
it's not the same way so you've
identified that as a dichotomy or
whatever uh but we don't I we don't want
to make any recommendation or or doing
well I think you're right in stating the
fact yeah that there's a difference way
of doing it in the two systems you know
the Community College um
oversees those
presidents yeah it would be interesting
not not for this group but I I'm
interested to see how did that current
usnh system evolve with a weak
Chancellor and the presidents I just I
have no I don't know the answer to that
but it been interesting to find out why
it was developed that way Dr Ed McKay
has that answer because I don't think it
was always like that okay and he in I my
discussions with in the past he's
explained it and I I just don't want to
you know yeah yeah shoot from my hip on
it yeah so then on the back side of that
number five then do we want to indicate
something to the fact that uh the role
of the chancellor at the
two current systems is
different that should be St that should
be stated yeah yeah so you got that
Jen I do thank you very much number
six is there an established set of
Benchmark performance measures to assess
progress toward a successful merger
outcome parenthesis performance
benchmarks along the flight path to
achieving the desired outcome um is what
I was trying to say there is that
there's a governance outcome we're
looking for and that would be to have
the singular form of government
governance but then there's all these
other policy
statements uh and and considerations
that must be looked at um I don't know
if we need that in parenthesis or not
but somewhere along the way if we're
going to recom and maybe this should be
taken out and if we have something down
below where we're going to say something
about a a a a council or an organization
to look at um uh what we talked about
there in the next next year maybe that
ought to be flowing down there with that
I think I agree with you on that Rick I
don't think the parenthetic note is
needed yeah okay I agree is that is that
where you want to also talk about the
differences in the mission with the
community
colleges I I think he addresses that a
little bit later Oliver okay yeah I
can't recall what this was put together
they make a big point in all of theirs
about having different missions yeah and
so I think we ought to be sensitive to
that let's let's flag that because I
think that you're absolutely right that
needs to be in there but I think he does
cover that later
okay lad you want to end at successful
merger outcome for number six is that
correct correct yes
yes so then we just go on number seven
here read this the the community college
system has an established educational
program to provide training and
education and skills essential to local
and Regional business will merger with a
four-year system overshadow the mission
of the current two-year and certificate
uh certificate Pathways offered by the
community college
system I think that's one of our real
yeah questions you might throw badges in
that
too okay uh um
um what what does that what does that
mean all ruins is badges it's kind of
like a merit badge is the only thing I
can come up with I think it in terms of
Scouts but that's what basically what it
is it says you've learned this little
specialized skill okay maybe it's a big
specialized skill but that's what it is
it's kind of a performance recognition
then yes yes it says that you're
qualified in well somebody's program
whatever it is all right okay so we
could put badges you know comma Badges
and then and and have that we've had the
discussion the education committee
regarding badges in the past and in New
Hampshire here we we never put it into
you know anything
because it was it was defined so
differently by everybody right yeah okay
then number eight number eight
affordability uh will the affordable
cost tuition at Community College remain
affordable or reflect increased costs
due to systemwide revenue
needs
good question just need to put a
question mark at the end of that oh yeah
oh yeah I see that
yeah so any problems with number eight
no okay uh number nine would the new
Board of Trustees and appointment
process be in
be in alignment I guess except in in
line accepted by the New England
uh I I I don't know if I that's written
properly at
all I'd just take out
in well I don't know if it's you try to
ask me I took this out of one of the
reports that came to us I think it was
the
alliance um but uh there's a question of
and I to asked this question earlier
today accreditation even in public K
through 12
the superintendent's office can be
accredited as an administrative office
um but in in postsecondary education and
I don't know this Oliver is the the
governance the the Chancellor's area
Administration do they get accredited or
is it just program and departments they
haven't in the past but these are
changing I had a letter into Barbara and
I I didn't get a chance to check my mail
yet see if she answered me but I was
asking exactly about that departmental
accreditation question yeah because I
don't really understand it I I don't
think number nine is needed in this
right
now well this does go to the question
that Oliver raised earlier this morning
regarding not necessarily the uh New
England higher education but the other
one that we had oh
yeah and and I think I think there is
some relevance from a standpoint
particularly what Barbara was talking
about is making sure who's on the
trustees and what are the standards that
they bring to the committee that they
just aren't political appointees but
they bring with them some of their
experience Etc so I do think that that
the concept of an outside agency looking
at what those standards would be I think
there is relevance there Rick so I think
that is true as far as trustees yes yeah
so should we re we like would the new
Board of Trustees in appointment process
uh be accepted by the New England higher
education Comm commission accrediting
standards yeah just take that align crap
out yeah just just you to have it
consistent yeah okay okay yeah be
consistent with the new yeah that's
good okay number 10 will the proposed
governance structure expand and simplify
or transfer articulation agreements
among the
institutions good I think there two
questions in that because there are a
lot of those that already exist and we
don't know about all of them so I think
we have to say existing and perhaps new
or some weasel language like
that okay will the proposed governance
structure expand and simplifly
simplify so how would you word that uh
because it says proposed does that mean
new well it just means that it's just
proposed it hadn't been agreed to yet
yeah okay so take the word proposed out
and put new yeah I think that's worth
leaving a little freedom in it
okay any objection no no okay number 11
what are the estimated cost savings and
efficiencies that should be expected
from this merger that's on the end if
any pardon me
everybody that's that's aund million
doll question right there that's well
you might want to put a comma if any at
the end of
it yeah uh right well do that question
that's the question Karen once answered
and uh I don't I don't have a good
answer but uh it's a good question okay
I like the idea let's put comma if any
in there thanks good suggestion well and
that and and Oliver is right I mean
that's been a consistent question that
has been raised by people we' talked
with that's right and nobody will give
you a guarantee no that's right did did
Governor Lynch's oped uh site any uh
numbers remember he was all for
this and I think part of the rash I
don't have it in front of me but when I
saw Governor Lynch former Governor Lynch
was all for this you know I got my
attention and I think he I think savings
was part of his
argument uh I don't know if he had a
number in there but I think that's been
a consistent um position of those
advocating for moving to this
immediately so
yeah okay let's go on to page 12 here
guys
gals um number 12 with a strong CEO I.E
the chancellor is it likely that the
coordination alignment across
institutions will occur more rapidly
than within the current two
systems yeah good question yeah and I I
would put I would put the chancellor in
parentheses after CEO I would too yeah
that's what we
mean even princes are question mark
princes I think if there's unified
structure unified command structure that
that is a is a is a
plus spoken like a true military
personen we appreciate
it number
13 uh will becoming part of a larger
system negatively impact the flexibility
of the community college system to
respond to student and Workforce demands
yeah yeah that's one of the big
questions
yeah okay number 14 mergers must be part
of a larger strategic plan and not an
isolated endpoint is the cost goal
savings significantly different from the
current postsecondary
system kind of convoluted a little bit
well it kind of assumes that they're
trying to do any cost cutting anywhere
else I think the savings are going to
come from Personnel we talked about
icity a duplication earlier and uh
clearly to me the the intent is to uh
reduce uh
Staffing uh you know you need one Pio
for the whole system instead of one Pio
for both systems having been a pi I mean
I think of that um so I think that the
the intent is to is to cut staff you
know somehow well that that goes that
goes back to the uh the back the what
they call it the back office structure I
think that fits into that Mike what's a
Pio but you know information
officer that too more military
talk sop standard operating procedure um
uh I I you know I don't know if I
necessarily agree it's labor is
obviously going to uh be impacted but
what about program yeah duplication of
program what about uh facilities older
structures uh are we going to close them
down are we going to consolidate um uh
maybe Community College into a fouryear
system at one location maybe in Keen um
so I don't know if it's just one issue
that they're look they're going to have
to look at all this duplic programs um
do we need to have a University of New
Hampshire
Manchester question I don't know yeah
yeah um it's just like University of
main Augusta do you need
that so close to gorum and so close to
Orno so yeah it's so but he gets around
some other questions on that Rick it's
the idea that some of those were
community colleges and they wanted to
offer a four-year degree and the simpler
solution was to call it a full year
fouryear
college yes that's that's they went
around the barn to do that and and we've
had that discussion too here in this
state and we've always said the two
years will remain two years not four
years but that might be changing as well
um so what do we do with this number
here I keep it can't do any harm I guess
no I don't think keep okay number 15
are funds available to support this
effort in the upcoming I put Bridge
years that came out of the Vermont study
the bridge year Bridge transition any
word like that
yeah yeah okay that we could put taking
they make question what's Bridge me you
could put transition in instead yeah I
think so yeah mergers have costs
building refurbishing necessary
infrastructure human and facilities and
branding um
um okay we can take all that bridge
stuff out similar to Vermont yeah okay
Rick would you we there was an 8 Million
number listed earlier today with vervant
is that kind of what do you think whe
that's where the8 million goes eight
million go or was that just I think I
think you could you could insert in
parentheses there uh the Vermont
legislature provided $8 million for the
transition process okay sense that makes
sense to
me they all make the point that you're
going to need to use some money to make
this happen yeah no matter which one of
these you look at they all say that yeah
yeah to make money you need money
yeah okay so we'll we'll insert that
that art said right there in parenthesis
number
um
is is the identified time frame for
achieving a
governance uh a change in governance uh
a governance change adequate that's a
big question yeah
yeah okay any objections to that one no
no number 17 will consolidation better
support student services and decrease
cost for academic
support what I'm not sure what that
means decrease cost two questions decre
decrease cost for academic support I'm
I'm not sure that what that reference is
yeah I think uh I think Oliver is
correct trying to say two thoughts in
one sentence and I think by doing that
neither one makes sense um well the
first part of the question about uh you
know student services I as a sports guy
I I I think in terms of teams and um I'm
not sure where this might go but if uh
for example if if a several campuses
were part of the same College uh then
then players from different campuses
could play in the same
team uh that's more of a community
college thing you're not going to have
you know UNH and teen sharing teams
particularly no but but UNH uh anyway
the sports piece of it the club piece of
it the organization piece of it the
student Senate piece of it uh all things
that are important parts of campus life
and uh consolidation of them I I I don't
know yeah you just mentioned a whole lot
there that it have to be really reframe
framed or
worked I I don't know about number 17 I
don't know if it's going to make a big
difference in our reporting
here
it's it decreasing cost for academic
support um that that's a definite
question is it are we going to be able
to provide something at a lesser cost
and therefore maybe reducing tuition
cost it's like we've had during the
pandemic where we've had some students
saying hey you know it's cheaper for you
to provide this online instruction than
it is for you to have the instructor in
the classroom or you know and they're
saying some students have said the value
of the online is not quite the same as
having the face to face with the
instructor yeah and that's why we have
seen a higher um failure rate amongst
incoming freshmen this last year they
weren't able to adjust to the
online uh impersonal way of instruction
as well as the Juniors and seniors
were that's what was told to me by folks
out of the
University yeah they're different parts
to that but I think what they're getting
at in this question is do can we cut
back somehow on student support and my
my sense is that depends on the number
of students no matter which system you
have it's really a sort of thing related
to how many people have to be
served yeah I because we've taken so
much trying trying to figure this out I
just take 17 out good point all right
yes okay 18
will potential Financial gains Beyond
those of shortterm reduction in
administration um
staff oh man this was late at night let
me tell you
um okay I mentioned 1995 earlier today
uh Governor Merill uh tasked the
community the technical colle system
with uh uh cutting staff and he got rid
of
uh three presidents uh we went from
seven presidents down to four which
saved whatever it saved but then you had
a little bit of an unwieldy situation
with u I'm trying to remember how
Claremont and Nash had the same
president so it certainly saved some
money but eventually they went back to
seven presidents so what I see people
looking at here and if there's any
college presidents listening to us talk
I I'm not trying to scare anybody I'm
not suggestions except that uh I'm sure
that as this moves forward people are
going to say do we need a president in
uh campus a and campus B which are close
to each other I'm not going to name any
campuses but I'm sure that is going to
be part of the thinking uh I'm not
recommending anything but having seen
this in 1995 I anticipate consolidation
and and having fewer presidents and is
part of this well see basically this
this if you took out the first part and
just put everything in parenthesis this
is really in support of merger
this is a consideration stating that
some states have seen that it it's you
know it has in included Financial
savings the leveraging of Greater size
and scale has been important and
transferability of course in credits has
been resolved um to some degree um it's
got a lot in it I don't know if it's
it's
needed represent Vlad if you like that
language would it make sense to move it
um like as um a secondary piece of
number 11 which are what are the
estimated cost cost
savings yeah maybe it goes in
there yeah you mean put the you're Jen
you're suggesting putting the
parenthetic note in number 11 yeah yeah
following you know if yeah that that
that's a good change yeah I think that
works thanks Jen yeah number
19 uh will the merger improve student
affordability accessibility Regional
identity and
compatibil and uh I would say
compatibility with regional business
needs job career
Pathways we had one already with
affordability haven't
we yeah number eight
on the on this sheet talks about
affordability but it talks about it in
terms of the Community
College here an awful lot of things in
that question aren't
there I think the point of this is if
there is savings that are gathered
through mer mer uh merger that those
savings can be passed down uh in terms
of tuition Sav savings and affordability
for students uh I think that's the
that's the whole intent of this is to is
to save uh money and and I know we want
to not um increase tuition so uh we the
merge a result or avoid duplication I
think that's the intent of this uh
clearly uh how to do it not our task but
um getting rid of duplication is a way
to save
money yeah getting rid of duplication a
way of saying money is correct um easy
for us to
say it sounds a lot easier to supply
priest and it does as a president
believe
me well I think you're right
accessibility and then the ne the end of
it Regional identity and compatibility
with regional business those are two
different things I think at least do
different things if not
three well how about if we just have
that will the merger improve student
affordability and accessibility
period that works for
me the jobs careers in in one of these
other questions anyway yeah I think it's
elsewhere in this thing yeah so let's
just put a period you know where the
comma is affordability and accessibility
period do you want to just add
accessibility to number eight that you
mentioned
earlier
or keep them I mean I keep I the way we
have
it okay
uh number 20 will the merger result in
or avoid duplication of academic
programs while optimizing access to
instruction have we talked about that
already the duplication thing
yeah I I see I was writing this stuff
late and I was just starting to repeat
and you know
so I I because it doesn't really mean
much to me right there um beyond what I
think we've already talked about i' take
number 20 out too because we remember we
got another couple sheets to look
at
any where are you guys on number
20 delete it yeah I don't have a problem
with deleting it okay let's do that okay
number 21 will the merger enhance
Regional Economic
Development well
that's that's back to n what we took out
of 19 basically
yeah
I must have been in somebody's report
that was dealing with economic
development and this about this
point but we took it out of the one I
let's leave it in here
then yeah I think it's a legitimate
issue yeah yeah I do too okay let's
leave 21 right there um number 22 you
can see as I getting more tired at night
the sentences don't make any sense will
the merger better student opportunity to
elevate or better enable students to
achieve higher education level skills
I what I was trying to do there I think
was that if there's a a stronger
relationship between the twos and the
fouryear systems could a student just
take courses without having to take
courses over again if they're going into
another program it's alignment of
courses and
materials but um I I think that uh um
the way it's
done is difficult and I don't know if
it's even necessary with where we're
going
here maybe you could just rephrase it
and to say does it facilitate the
transition from one level or kind of
program into another throughout the
university that's what sort of like
number 23 is Will barriers to
transferring credits be reduced I think
we've asked it then I don't think you
need to ask it again yeah the which one
23 yeah the one you're just talking
about okay so 23's out no I I thought we
said 23 was in and 22 is
out whichever yeah see I was going to
take uh 23 and put it in and 22 out okay
okay whichever okay we just don't need
both yeah we don't need both uh 24 with
two and fouryear programs working
jointly on the same campus or within the
region
um uh region better assist a four-year
institution in aligning supporting
Regional Workforce demands
needs I think we've sort of talked about
that already yeah yeah so it's not I
don't think you want to compromise the
mission on the fouryear schools by
fudging it into the need to back
industry for the community colleges yeah
that's there baileywick okay so let's
take
24 25 will the missions of the community
colleges and universities be preserved
hb2 identifies a purpose what is the
proposed overall mission of the proposed
New Hampshire Community uh in University
system question mark will this Mission
support current missions of the two
institutions or supplant those mission
statements and current institution
missions yeah I think the first part of
that can be
eliminated because you really are
addressing that the the first
sentence in the last two
sentences so where where would you start
this thing if you keep
it I would start with it what is the per
proposed overall
mission I would start that that question
with that set that
question okay what is the proposed
overall mission of the proposed uh New
Hampshire college and university system
will the mission support current
missions of the two-year or supplant
those mission statements yeah
okay okay you got that
Jen I see H Dave's with us yes all
David we're on 26 of
uh what we're doing is we've just gone
down through and um identified those
which we'll keep out of this paper and
those change
so we moved along Jen has to be out of
here by 2:30 okay sounds good sounds
good okay okay number 26 will the new
system have a single student application
document used by the entire system or
will each institution have its own Penn
State system has one upon receiving the
application the student preparedness is
reviewed and the student may not be
enrolled in the main campus but another
smaller campus
um better oriented to the students
Readiness um that that's something that
this system has talked about having one
application and so you don't have to
fill out one for Keane one for Plymouth
one for UNH and you only have to pay one
fee and and then uh if you're applying
for UNH but UNH says we don't think this
is really a kid that's qualified for UNH
Maybe maybe Keen State might be a better
place but they wouldn't have to apply
again they'd be accepted the keen on one
application so it's uh it's a concept
that some colleges are moving systems
are moving towards um I don't know if
it's something we've discussed here so
maybe we don't need to put it
in well and Al Rick it also raises for
me the sort of the issue around the
community colleges at this point where
two or three of them may specialize in a
certain Hospitality or whatever that's
what you would be applying for but it
would not be available necessarily at
the other four right just a question on
it so I I I don't know 26 it's it's I
don't think we need it no I don't need
it here no okay number 27 will all
levels of education and offered degrees
receive equal attention and
support will certification be given the
type of support that the four-year
program is
that's like being handed a firecracker
with a fuse
[Laughter]
lit if it doesn't if it doesn't you know
hit you like we need it we just don't
put it in you're gonna have to qualify
with as needed or something like that
well let's leave it out
yeah okay by joining Community College
and UNH system will the two-year and the
certificate programs lose their
effectiveness in supporting recruiting
the more traditional students good
question yep I agree yeah I I that's one
we asked this morning with a traditional
student
um
will okay what about 29 here will the
transfer of credits between colleges and
universities remain an
issue we picked that up already in an
earlier question okay so eliminate it
I'm ask ask a question oh number 23 okay
thank you so so Rick yeah um Ju Just on
that one by itself um I I I I think we
heard um quite a bit of of testimony uh
and and particularly this morning too on
um on that issue and that may be
something that we could
suggest uh the um the current um two
boards of Trustees look to um
begin um expanding credit transfer uh
opportunities I agree with you Dave
that's going to be an issue down the
road it's got to be looked at somewhere
yeah I think I think you do ask that
though in 23 all right agree yeah but I
I liked what Oliver said you know this
morning too that in some cases it could
just be getting you know getting Dean
offices
together
yeah it's also that you have individual
departments being
accredited and or
programs and they're accredited by
institutions not NE not necessarily NY
that they're accredited by The Nurses
Association or this T of abet for
engineering technology yeah or speech
pathologist you
know so okay so we do have that in 23 um
going into 30 could the merger result in
more Balor degree programs being offered
in a regional location presently served
only by community college
system could you have fouryear degrees
offered at White
Mountain White Mountains mountains yes
yes
yes well the closer the closer place is
nhti they've been nudging toward it for
a long long time in teacher
Ed yeah yeah I I think that's a that's
an important question to uh okay let's
let's leave it in there then Dave okay
31 will affordability of the community
colleges be lost with a
merger didn't we ask that question
earlier another form I think we did uh
number
eight yes we did right there number
eight affordability yeah okay I guess
another way of asking the question is
can it be
well we're going to eliminate it okay
well that's one way to take care of it
okay okay because we got it basically
well we're getting done this we on the
third sheet now uh how can the issue of
multiple Union contracts be handled
without disrupting merger efforts big
bonfire yeah a huge huge
tsunami I I I didn't realize that they
had 11 contracts at the community colge
amazing
yeah and we didn't hear how many they
have at UNH we know that there's one for
the professors at the
Keen one of the questions I have that I
don't know the answer to Is can the
university in this situation say can you
all come together and ask them to unify
under one Union not our choice their
choice but that's what happened at L we
just did it yeah because they they had
more votes than we had so they we took
their Union and I was the president and
so it was just one of those kind of
Common Sense decisions Oliver you could
do that back in 1960 This Is 2020 I know
well and and the D being old and one of
the dilemas you've got you know you've
got different Internationals
representing these respective uh oh yeah
collective bargaining agreements and as
and as Oliver said that can be
jurisdictional questions can be a real
issue too so and I think that has to be
figured out legally before we can really
have any say in it oh yeah exactly
question Shannon Reed might have some um
she got her hand
up I
know Shannon Reed has her hand up as
Shannon Reed might have some information
to bear on
this is she there right now yeah you
want to recognize her yeah
yeah I see her
there Shannon welcome hi thanks just
very quickly and I know this is ession
for people like me to talk but I just
heard someone say that they heard that
the community college system has 11
barging units and that is not the case
we only have three bargaining units one
across our whole system for full-time
faculty one across our whole system for
adun faculty and one across our whole
system for staff that's it I thought to
clear that up I thought I thought uh
Susan said they had 11 no we have we
have 11 locations seven main campuses
and then a handful of academic centers
in places like Littleton okay and
Lebanon but only three bargaining
units thank you thank you very much yeah
makes it a little easier yeah yeah okay
okay 33 will a merger offer better
opportunity to assess and possibly
eliminate duplication of programs
offered within the
system maybe you want to stick
necessarily in that
question where well will they
necessarily
reduce in other words they I think the
question they they might be needed you
might need it in two different places
because of demand doesn't mean you
should cut it down to none or one just
you know
yeah there are programs that you have
within a university sometimes that
program may not bring any Revenue in the
pay for it so it's offset from revenue
somewhere else within the system I.E
maybe our law school but right but you
can't get rid of it well we should I was
just thinking you might have it on both
sides of the state a program in somebody
else said Hospitality earlier but you
could have those and serve people on the
coast and people in the mountains
you know and and it's not even though
it's duplication it's needed
duplication is this a needed question or
consideration just for the record you
rejected a similar one
earlier thank you
Jen number
20 um you
know I I don't think it's needed all
right
eliminated because I'm relying on the
other sheets you guys put together to
have something like
it well the the council's gonna come up
with more questions too right of course
they are that's right that's right
number 34 as occurred in Maine in the
70s the four systems fouryear system
rapidly expanded to a smaller
communities Okay blah blah blah this
satellite expansion resulted in New
Capital and operational costs that are
now unsustained able without significant
increases in state support or other
Revenue sources such as tuition and fees
as a small state New Hampshire also has
small institutions with capital and
operation costs that duplicate Services
of the larger or main institution is the
new board task in identifying duplicity
and if necessary recommending closure of
any of the two or four years
institutions there's a lot there that's
a huge hug question that's even bigger
than than Oliver's
firecracker well take duplicity out
anyway even if
a yeah you want
duplication I think that it's you know
it's probably it's just too much um it
may be
unanswerable at this point in time right
we're talking a different story right
now here governance and and some of
those other issues which we previously
offered for
consideration have we addressed so any
other questions um and Jen I'm looking
for you for this have we about the issue
of of capital costs capital on
operational costs have we have we
addressed that in another question
because that is an important question
here dealing with capital and
operational costs
the duplicity of those
and that that question's been bounced
around by the trustees when I was there
many a time yeah uh especially wasn't
thisle dealing with the campuses it was
dealing with
program um so one of the things you
might want to allow for is things
happening in the future we can't
anticipate for example at L they kept
the music program beautiful buildings
all kinds of wonderful music stuff and
then the schools stopped having school
music programs and the entire Market
Drive Drew up just dried out went away
and they didn't have any choice but to
close the College of Music because there
wasn't anybody hiring music teachers and
that just sort of popped on the horizon
and suddenly that whole issue became a
place they could save money
on so so so maybe maybe along the lines
of what Oliver was saying uh is to cast
this question a different way to um to
you know evaluate the um the
resources um uh in order to meet um
demands student need and the marketplace
or something like that did you get that
Jen not quite can you say it again Dave
so so just sort of recasting it as
opposed to you know uh you know closing
things just um being able to to adapt um
um highered resources in order to meet
the needs of students and the um um
greater um economy or Market changing
Market demands
yeah um so I've got will will the merger
facilitate adaptation to changing Market
demands yeah yeah
good number 35 is there an exception
expectation that all institutions will
continue to be independently
accredited that that I think that's an
important question because we we raised
that with Brit brittenham this morning
regarding um the meaning of
accreditation and how it how will impact
then she mentioned the issue of the the
university system in uh in Maine how
they try to have a system wide
accreditation of programs yeah I would
suggest in this one we say initially yes
and then it will be reconsidered by the
new Chancellor once in office or
something to that
effect I mean right right now we've got
two systems and every institution in
those systems is separately accredited
right yeah yes
yeah and some programs within those
institutions are accredited have
specific accreditations right yeah
nursing engineering technology stuff
like that yeah but you'll just scare
people if you say you're going to change
them from day one
yeah hey Rick I have a timeline question
um if I could we're looking they're
looking to have something in place by
like uh June July 1st of 03 of of 2003
right
2023 it's a different
bium um because this is going to be a
the intent of this is to save money uh
and to cut cut cut that's just the
reality it's going to be very
painful and it's not our job to make
those decisions other than to just flag
questions but my question to to you or
anybody is um 2023 is a different bium
it'll be a different
legislature
uh if if a new chancel comes in and they
come up with a plan that cuts all this
stuff uh could this all be thrown out by
a new
legislature in
23 well that's always a possibility but
my sense is if if we
created a process that's that's
nonpartisan or bipartisan I mean this is
this is a kind of a an issue that we're
all concerned about so my hope Mike
would be that if if the planning is done
appropriately that the rec
recommendations will be sustained uh I
think the real question is going to be
it always comes down to the funding part
I mean regardless of the structure you
have there's going to be dollar signs
behind it and so I think that's going to
be the real question about how how it
can be
measured well we're just flagging
questions here we're not really making
any exactly right yeah but the key uh
Matt Mel and everybody is uh whoever is
on whatever committee is put together
together to make these tough decisions
uh I know when Ray Burton was up uh in
district one you know was talking about
uh closing Burling Berlin or cutting
back on Berlin way way back and Ray said
Over My Dead Body and Ry was right um so
it's going to be a a a political you
know folks are going to mobilize to save
their campus or their program um so
anyway I'm just I'm just trying to
anticipate um how this is going to play
out uh I I don't know I I just uh it's
going to be hard and uh well that that's
why I think it's so
key to have a strong planning process
because in that planning process like my
presumption is is that those voices are
going to be heard now granted some tough
decisions may have to be made but at
least if the process is clean and is
transparent it would seem to me that
that the ultimately the ultimate
decisions that are made are going to be
more Universal than they are if they're
just for example in just the budgetary
process that has limited input from all
the P part parties that are involved in
this thing so I you know I think the
transparency question I think hopefully
will address some of the issues that
you're concerned about and I'm concerned
about too so well a cautionary tale here
is what happened in verar a year ago
they had their Chancellor or their head
guy uh who recommended closing Johnson
and closing l
and they a week later he was gone and uh
they they kept those both campuses open
to some degree so who whoever is whoever
is the the head guy here I guarantee
they're going to be aware of what
happened to Vermont I'm just I'm just
thinking ahead uh
process-wise anyway well Mike I think
you're absolutely correct in terms of I
there will be a human cry coming out
regarding ing White Mountains Community
College if something happens there that
the North Country survives around that
Community College and it's it's it's
part of the E it's an economic driver in
that neck of the woods uh I I think
you're gonna see that there that's one
of the reasons why um uh some people may
be advocating a Slowdown here to get
some assurances that Community College
is going to still continue to serve the
mission that they have been tasked to do
with these outlying
areas so uh what number are we on now I
think we're on
uh the I think we're on number
36 with the decline in K through 12
students can New Hampshire afford not to
merge
institutions that's a question good
question yeah yeah it needs to be
answered you that that enrollment that
demographic is really uh causing a lot
of Heartache K through 12 and
postsecondary so so I I think related to
that Rick um would would be the the
question of what's expected from a
merger that's going to improve the um
the the the way the university system
and the community college system will be
able to respond to um to student uh
needs or student demand and um and also
related to that I think is would a um
would how would a merger potentially
complicate the ability of the two
systems to um to Pivot more quickly or
respond more quickly to changes in
Market demands as I think what you
mentioned earlier Dave what you
mentioned earlier how will this how will
a merger impact this demographic change
uh is the is the issue how is the the
the merger going to really impact how uh
we address this loss of
students yeah how is how is the merger
part of the solution yeah yeah and and
you know you know let's just say
everything was perfect right now
everything's perfect and we want to
merge the two systems that's a huge
undertaking right there at least from
everything I think we've read and heard
um and so so so could emerger complicate
the um development of
solutions I think we're getting now down
into some of the considerations when I
was reading the materials that came in
from uh the day we had the university
system um respond to us in Wednesday I'm
just looking at 36 on downwards and a
lot of them deal with
this so Jen did you get the possible
change there to
36 afterward it says K through 12
students how will the uh proposed
merger what you say influence or impact
or help cont contribute to um to
addressing to meeting the market needs
yeah
yeah of New Hampshire students of New
Hampshire well it's it's it's it's that
but also it's it's Market
needs because we serve more than just
New Hampshire students we kind of used
that language in number
34 34 we took out didn't
we well we took out and replaced it with
how will the merger facilitate
adaptation to changing Market
demands yeah
great so is that the same or different
I would say student Market demands so
it's clear what the I think Market
demands is the market is driving the
whole nine yards here all right okay all
right yeah it's it's it's it's economy
it's yeah you know okay Market
yeah it's okay if we have a couple that
are sort of the same but you know we're
getting a point across let's go on to
the next one 37
37 can the community college system and
University system sustain the following
conditions net tuition decline
significant student population declines
with a
projected a projected continuance oh
yeah projected declines I think you
could have it stop right there high
levels of student debt high levels of
student tuition a regional decline in
eligible post-secondary students costs
associated with the pandemic and other
structural changes challenges
lot in there what was the what was the
time of the night that you put that one
in there it it was probably closing in
close to 11
o' you want to leave it out fine leave
it out I no no I I you know but I think
we got to address um the the student
debt that we haven't talked about um
student debt is causing a lot of people
to say I'm not going to go to school
yeah high cost same deal yeah I I I
think it's an important question I think
maybe open it up to be a how will as
opposed to can yeah okay and and um and
you know with with respect to to student
debt um you know that cuts both ways too
both in terms of the um the maybe I'm
scared
Away by you know know the possibility of
student debt um and then if I incur a
lot of student debt uh can I continue to
afford my higher education and if I
don't attain a degree um you know what
then I mean the the student debt issue
is a huge issue
yeah representative glad um in that
first um Clause after the colon net
tuition declines is that tuition Revenue
declines yeah it would be the revenue
yeah but okay I'm just gonna add that
word then
yeah
yeah um baked into that that question
too Rick um do you is there a because
you've got student
debt um what about things like like um
like um financial
aid yeah that's part of it as well
because now we're having to give more
financial aid at the same
time the increase the increased need of
financial aid yeah where's that going to
come
from the revenue of the support
financial aid well you know what one of
the things we heard was you know back in
the day the the decision for tuition be
placed so high was to was to basically
provide the the um the 100 100% of
need and and then at some point I think
what did what did we learn 10 years ago
we dropped the 100% of
need part meeting 100% of need
uhuh so so that that was there I think
to justify the uh the the higher than
average U you know on a state basis uh
tuition
costs
MH well we're not getting into the the
national Politics on this but was
mentioned by someone that there is a
proposal to double theel Grant
eligibility which whatever happened with
that yeah that would feed into the
student sort of the student debt thing
at some point yeah yeah and and and the
things that Mike's talked about too with
regards to maybe other tuition you know
programs that are being discussed at the
federal level so we probably want to
incorporate I mean that's a big it's a
big question but it's all related
yeah so do we have enough in there right
now to convey what we're trying to
convey go ahead Mike well I I had a
couple things I wanted to say but I
didn't want to say them until we were
done ready
for are you you don't want to do it
right
now okay real quick I think I'm not sure
if there's a question to this effect but
I think Pro probably the most important
question we need to ask and I'm not sure
if it's been asked clearly is who are
going to be the decision makers and
stakeholders that are going to implement
the the new structuring and it's
critically important it's like uh
whatever happens will be a function of
the makeup of the committee
or the the board or whoever is going to
be making these decisions and unless the
board has some highly respected like Gus
G guson Walter Peterson types uh John
Lynch types uh crucial uh because if the
board is seen as being stacked it won't
work now I don't know how how that's
going to be uh
determined uh and you know there needs
to be uh you know Regional meetings and
all kinds of input and we're going to be
you know there's going to be people
lobbying and and arguing for their
campus and their program big time so
this committee is going to have some
guts um and some finesse and some
patience to make this work it's
gonna it's got to be the good people I
don't know who they are but Walter
Peterson's no longer here but people
like that and also you know I'm also
wondering if if we will have next year
in House Education next January uh bills
related to this I I don't know I'm I'm
just I can just see people putting
preemptively proposed legislation to uh
you know try to save some some peace at
their a so anyway uh my big point is to
me about the most important question is
who is going to be making the final
decisions well it's going to be your
your trustees are going to be making
that decision that that board of
governance the fif the 15 yeah and and
the see and we heard today that you know
the way we're we're proposed to set it
up here according to hb2 is that there's
so many coming out of this level so many
out of this level and then we have this
other group then we have a number of
other people that are exop ficio types
um and down the roadways it's going to
be one system it's no longer going to be
premised upon Community College or this
supposedly and and so it's just like
you're selecting board if you a lot of
different precincts within your
community some folks advocate well I
have to have one from this Precinct one
from this Precinct but you're acting on
behalf of the total town and you got to
get away from that regionalism you got
to go for your mission what's your
mission to have something that works um
for all so so so I think that report
that that letter that Dr bringham um
provided us this morning and spoke to
this morning I think has some
um important elements for that Rick for
the con for the constituencies of that
group well for the for the
constituencies but also the size the
voting right you know things like that
and and um and obviously you know the
work that they do has to be durable in
nature and not U not you know
politically flighty or anything like
that so okay so so what we need to do on
this discussion that Mike brought up
because we're getting a
from this but we needed to put that down
on on a piece of paper beside us hey we
got to get back to that that's got to be
added in here let's do that at the end
of the question that's exactly so so is
37 good the way it is or do we want to
dump it what's the the feeling of the
committee we got to get by this quickly
here Jen's gonna have to leave here
shortly I think she put financial aid
and some other stuff into it yeah I
added high demand for financial aid
yeah okay let's go on to
38 can the state continue to sustain
support the community college system at
the current funding
level I don't know if that's really
relevant to the
merger well dropped that one
yeah because every is going to say we
always need more and they probably do 39
the merger proposal is accompanied with
a 9% cut in state Support over two years
for the combined system from that that
fiscal year okay so that's just a
statement you know you could you could
turn it into you know develop a develop
a cash flow U or CA yeah cash flow
analysis based on merger activities yeah
what would be the cash
flow the cash flow directed to merger
efforts
yeah can you work something around that
uh
Jen sure cash
flow are we talking about the eight
million that we stuck in the number 15
or no that's the bridge money that's the
transition money I got it well well the
this would this would be that as as well
Rick I think it's related so so money
that would have to go in additional
money that would have to go into a
merger effort and and money that would
spring coming out of a merger effort as
well through efficiencies or something
like that see this this right here
though is looking at money that cost now
what the projecting cost will
be yeah it it so does the cash flow yeah
over a period of years okay let's go on
to number
40 can UNH compete and remain
competitive with you UMass when out of
state institutions are undercutting
tuition and offering New Hampshire
students in state tuition
rates that's one of the reasons
why we may be in trouble yeah that's a
reality that's part of the reality check
that we're talking about here I I think
I changed the question into how does New
Hampshire
yeah increase its competitiveness okay
okay yeah good point Oliver yeah okay
good next question is very
similar can the New Hampshire system
survive when the state remains an
exporter of graduating high school
students I think we've already addressed
that in a couple of other questions okay
good number 42 the legislator should be
more involved in through uh involved
through the public higher education
study committee pursuant to be engaged
in this process that committee has
specific responsibility to examine the
goals purposes organization and
financing of higher education in New
Hampshire yeah I think the question
there is
what yeah the question there I think is
what is the
role what should the what should the
what should the the role be of the
higher education study Comm well we
already know what that is that's in
statute the legislature knows that
so what is the role for that group to
participate in this process there is at
this point in time it's not so Senator
Ward is the head of that correct right
now yes yeah the the chair of the senate
committee education committee this year
I was there last year it alternates back
and forth Mike one year one session it's
a Senate the other is the house the
senator Ward would be the convenor I
guess
correct so I'm not sure if anybody's
talk to her
about no I don't think for on the
committee this year on her side you have
Senator Ward Senator Reagan and Lou
delandro so is this question intended to
be what will
be no I think it was more of a question
that uh the
this I guess it's a just a statement to
the legislature we need to get engaged
exactly well you know in in last year's
last session's um higher education study
commission uh we did learn a lot of
things that I think manifested in um in
in legislative action one of them I
think related to um to institu U debt
and um and how they go about um um
issuing
bonds Mel do you remember that yeah yeah
right it's part of it's part of the
report yeah so so um um so I I would I
would say not you know not losing sight
of the higher education commission's you
know role in um in the financial
sustainability of our higher ed system I
know the year that I chaired that group
there was a a huge discussion on whether
the community college should have offer
four-year degree program
yeah and Ross was pushing that and of
course there was you know it didn't make
it I think I I think it's the fact that
we have it it's in the it's in the law
and it somehow is going to have to be
part of this process so I think just
mentioning it putting it in is important
so I think it's and I think if there's a
a council a group that's going to be
during the Slowdown that we're looking
at a coordinating Council they need to
report to this
body at certain
benchmarks uh whatever the time frame
may be or we need to have that body or
some represent representation from the
house involved in that
body um I don't want to be driving the
getting down on micromanaging don't want
to do that I want the folks that uh
Barbara brittenham was really saying you
have to have those knowledgeable people
in that job not that legislators are not
but uh uh we need to be informed so it
comes back to the question again is what
is the role of this higher education
study committee in this merger
proposition well that that last sentence
there comes right out of Statute yeah
the committee has specific
responsibility to examine the goal the
purposes um organization and financing
of the higher education and it
specifically States the four
universities and Community College
system so I think if you say what is the
role in light of that last
sentence that's the question what his
role in light of the merger proposal
yeah right yeah so so so Rick I think
it's a good question I think the higher
education study commission can certainly
provide information to the um the the
merger what are we calling it now merger
Council yeah we haven't we haven't put a
tag on it yet we hav gone there yet Dave
yeah yeah but but um but I think it I
think it needs to be really clear of
what the role of the whatever we're
calling the the the merger um commission
or the merger Council what its role is
in terms of reporting back to the
legislature and EXE the legislative I I
think we got to go even deeper than that
I think we what is the role of this
higher education group in terms of The
Proposal in
hb2 to merge you know that's what the
whole thing is about we're changing our
system all
around and and yet we have in statute
right now a process which we're supposed
to be informed and
involved so it you know what is the role
of the higher education study committee
in regard to the proposal as identified
in
hb2 okay I think something that this uh
the higher educ a study committee could
do would be a very limited uh Mission or
role perhaps would be to do what I think
is maybe the most crucial thing which is
identify uh 10 20 30 40 50 potential
members of the board that that will be
so important in in to screen them and
and you know just to to do that piece of
it is I think is a very limited Mission
but very important missions that's just
one one
idea see I don't want politics to start
steering that ship either but yeah I I I
do believe that we need to be engaged in
this this process and it shouldn't be
after the fact this this statutory
language which is in 187a is there for a
reason it's just like you were talking
about what you identified last in the
last
bium state your question again about the
role because I think you I think that
was
it
um what is the role of
the public higher education study
committee and then you can put pursuant
the RSA in regard to proposed
language reflected concerning the merger
of the the the the postsecondary
education uh in HB to I I like what Mike
was
suggesting because I think that we we
haven't even come we we haven't even
asked that question or certainly
answered answered it where where do
these members come from but that's a
second qu that's a secondary
question that's that's that could be the
role for the higher education
committee to in in consultation with
let's say the system boards and the
chancellor I create a stable of
potential board members it can be uh 50
people who knows but that I think that
they that might be a good role for them
and it's limited and clear and uh and
not hopefully fairly nonpolitical I mean
without recommending anybody
specifically just
identify uh really good people that
people respect and trust and can work
together and get get 50 names and and
then uh can go from there yeah yeah yeah
I don't know if I agree with that uh
it's I think that we're just getting a
little bit outside of where we need to
be as a legislature I think that we're
looking at people that are in the the
system right now that are quite capable
I'm not anywhere near I don't have the
capabilities that a Don Burks has I
don't have that and when I'm looking at
and I don't know all the little ins and
outs that are necessary for to make this
thing work whereas the the person like
ausan hu is the person like a Don Burks
is um the person like a Todd leech is um
those are the people that you know live
and breathe it and know it um yes there
should be others not just Educators I
agree but um you know you I I think you
you were looking at a system which is is
going to be hiring a CEO and developing
a system which is huge business in our
state uh I I think we need to have that
expertise um when we're trying to
identify them let me tie this into
something called bra BR base closing and
realignment commission and and that was
to do what we're trying to do uh we had
too many uh military bases around the
country and uh Schwarz goof wanted to
close a base in Arkansas and Senator MCL
said you're never going to close that so
what they did they they created
a independent commission that was
ostensibly free of politics and they
took politics out of it and they just
looked at criteria for which bases to
close now that's what we're talking
about here so all I'm saying is that the
notion of having a New Hampshire version
of Brack uh who will uh look at criteria
make recommendations with his little
politics is you you take Ray Burton out
of it uh you know what I said before
about Ray saying you'll never close
Berlin so anyway that this Brack model
might be something we somebody might
want to look at a little
bit well for purpose of moving on
because we're going to have to identify
that when we get to this bottom line
when we're making a recommendation for
establishing a slow down coordinating
type Council
um I for this particular statement right
there I'm trying to just get the this
particular committee engaged in this
process and at this point it's not been
involved and there's there hasn't been
any effort to involve them um so we have
stepped in and filled that void this
group right here but once we get this
report and we are able to do that
because we were requested by the finance
division 2 to do that we don't have any
statutory authority to be going ahead
and doing an independent study like
this I don't believe but let's let's mik
let's hold the Brack conversation once
we get through these other questions
because I do think there needs to be a
conversation about what that
coordinating group might look like which
is what you're talking about yeah so
let's get through the questions and then
we'll deal with that composition yeah so
so so Rick um
um our work group is really an ad hoc
work group right yeah yeah and and so
you know we we've we've formed up the
higher educ higher education study
commission exist committee exists right
now and um and it may not be a bad idea
for um for maybe Rick and Ruth to talk
about
um all of us getting together at a
higher education study commiss committee
meeting talk about some of these things
find out what role they want to play in
it they are the formal um
legislative um oversight committee not
us and um uh but we can we can help with
with with the Trans with the I don't
know what do you want to call it um
because we've been working on this for
two weeks yeah I I think that's that's
appropriate Dave
um
the question I think there is a question
around what is the role of this
committee going to be yeah I think that
we got word 42 asking that question what
is the role of the higher education
Commission in regard to hb2
right okay let's get on to the next one
here because we got to go through the
other sheet as well um what is the
expected let's see where are we now yeah
what is the expected timeline Beyond
merch
governance
43 43 I I don't that's you know I think
that's that's the that's a what if type
question and I don't think it's
necessary I can live with
that I'd like to start on the sheet that
Dave and
uh Mel put together here because we got
another I I think as we as as go this I
think we've covered some of the it's not
new territory here so we can should be
able go through this through this pretty
quickly yeah okay so let's go on number
one on on that sheet right now and the
first question is what should be the
mission of the higher educ of higher
education in New
Hampshire good question I think I think
that is the the I don't think think we
asked that specifically we talked about
missions but I think what is the what
what are we trying to do is a pretty
basic question as we get into this uh
whole merger
question you know and and uh I I could
combine number two into number
one um you know what should be the
mission of the higher education in New
Hampshire and is the current education
mission of community Consciousness
compatible yes yeah just no no I I think
that's two separate questions because I
think in question two it's are they
compatible with each other not whether
they're compatible with the mission of
higher education are you saying in
number two that the community college
and you're asking if those two missions
are
compatible that's how I read it
yeah true y okay so that you're looking
at it from a different angle yeah so
there two there are two separate
questions there okay so I'm good with
one and two how about everybody else
yes number three what would be the
authority of the merger commission what
what commission is this now well this is
the this would be the the group that
would be looking at this whole thing
okay so that would be this coordinating
Council that talking about exactly okay
we're going to take that up at the
bottom of all this and and talk about
that so skipping over to number four is
it possible to create a merged system
and still provide autonomy for each
campus we've talked about that that's
you've already asked that question have
we where y it was in one of the
questions that you you posed
Rick okay I can't remember it must been
real late last night no you show me
where it is
now well okay Jen I'll trust Jen yeah we
we've asked that
question but if it's not clear Jen could
maybe merge it into yeah something
earlier if you read something like that
Jen and you don't see it merge this in
with that
question thank you number five what
should be the business model to maximize
the resources of the current
systems what's meant by
that Dave so it's it's really it's it
that's the merger plan yeah yeah and so
so what you're what what you've what
you've got right now is you're taking
two um separate um organizations and
merging them into into one organization
so there has to be a business plan for
that and um and you know just like you
would have if one company was buying you
know two companies were getting together
so by business model are you talking
about organizational
structure um not I'm not talking so much
about that but it could certainly
include that um but uh but guess what
are the you know generally when when two
organizations are getting together the
the the um the the sum is has has
greater value than the than the parts do
separately and and so what what would
what you know where does that value um
stem from flow from and how how they
would do their
business okay is there any objection to
that
number five what should be the business
model to maximize the resources of the
current
systems know what we just did that's
what we just did
six must be that Co shot oh yeah right
how can a merg system guarantee that the
Community College voice does not get uh
subu
subsumed uh by the larger University
system we had something like yeah we had
that we've had we've we've asked that a
question we've asked that one that's
that's done okay number seven how can a
merger maximize the student centered
focus on their needs and those of the
economy of the
state yeah two questions there I think
we've asked that
question we we've talked a lot about
business and Pathways and Regional this
and that exactly right well it's the
accommodating Market Market needs yeah
yeah
yeah adapting to Market demands yeah
okay this next one's kind of a a big one
uh what would the administrative
management structure of a merge system
look like there are a lot of options out
there yeah um for how you set your
governance
up a lot of different
models
um is it defined in
hb2 I don't think it is no it's
not Mike you have your hand fluttering
up no I'm just holding my head
up he got the shot too yesterday's
fluttering
yeah okay I'm wondering if this question
shouldn't be a qualitative question
rather than ask what is ask what is the
most effective or most efficient or
something that's I like that better
other words they they're going to have
to look at them all and say okay what is
the model which best F New Hampshire
that's good I like that too yeah it's a
good Mike I think you're leaning on
something on your keyboard I think so
too yeah let me uh I'll get out and try
to get back in sorry okay okay no Oliver
I think that was a good that's a good
suggestion do you have Jen what he
suggested what oliv Oliver do you want
to repeat for
her
well I'm I'm sorry did were you asking
me to repeat yeah what you had proposed
so Jen get that down what is the
uh forgot what I said ideal or or most
efficient most
effective most
effective okay if you can get something
like that down Jen that'd be fine number
n how should a merger board of directors
be
selected a merger
board so is that of
the are you talking the Board of
Trustees here talking the fiduciary
board yeah the fiduciary board so you're
talking about the new board that's the
overarching board okay yeah
yeah
so that so that board is different than
what you've been talking about Rick the
planning board I got that yeah about the
five five and five yeah y yep
okay okay number 10 I think we've talked
about that does a CEO structure fit we I
think we talked about the CEO process
earlier so we're good there okay what
specific cost savings can be achieved
with a merger system ah there I think
we've got that in the business plan
question yeah we asked that question I
think we have in several places that's
good we do yeah uh how does the
consolidation engage representation of
each
campus um there there's a couple other
campus related questions from the last
set and maybe this could be merged into
that if it needs to be
well it's a legitimate question and if
we could just leave it there it's not g
to do any harm all right just leave it
there then yeah yeah okay how will
tuition levels be
established board kind of an interesting
question yeah
yeah you see is the University tuition
level going to drive the tuition level
of the Community College yeah you know I
think we asked that question Jen in
another questions we did we talked about
maintaining levels and all that stuff so
I think we've already asked that
question okay I think we have
too I think we did that prior to Dave
getting here um
yeah okay number 14 how does one merge
the various Information Technology
systems all that one we have not asked
we've not asked that and that was one of
the issues that Susan brought up on
Wednesday from the multiple the
university system their system and it is
a com it is complex yeah Barber brought
it up this morning too yeah yeah yeah
okay number
15 should the current search for a new
Chancellor be postponed until a decision
is made on a new higher education
structure legitimate question yeah we've
heard that they're moving forward yeah
um both of them so so re related to this
so so what we heard from from Susan
Huard was that they're moving forward
with an interim Chancellor for the
community college system um should there
be a parallel effort to move forward
with an interim Chancellor for the
University
system so so so the the query is David
then is should they postpone the process
or who's
name uh
the the respective institutions should
they should each one postpone or your
question should they hire an interim
during the during this planning period I
so what right so what we heard from
Susan is that the community college
system interim is going to be singularly
focused no I don't want to say she said
that is is knows that that it's an
interim
role yeah right um
and and so so you know are there interim
roles and and can two interim
chancellors of the respective system
respective systems contribute to the um
U uh effort for a
merger well there's also the question
that I would I would perceive that the
budget for we may have one year where
you still have a budget that's for the
community college and a budet budget for
the higher education folks so oh yeah
okay now so are you going to need a
Chancellor yeah yeah yeah and
and
yeah
so I
um I I I have no problem with leaving 15
there okay oh yeah yeah okay number 16
how can course alignment and credits
transferred uh be more effectively
available for students we've asked that
question we've asked that question yep
uh what would the merger impact B on
various accreditations accreditation
currently available within each
institution I think we've asked that too
we've asked that question
yep okay what are the current
collaboration efforts within the
institution that that's an interesting
question we have not asked and and it
and it was mentioned by Susan again in
her uh com comments about that there
have been efforts of the respective
schools to look at procurement Etc but
that we have not asked this question yet
yeah see that's that that's exactly
right I've asked both chancellors that
that question how have you how are you
trying to coordinate you know between
the two and procurement is one that
they've been working on for several
years and they've looked at the issue of
uh of assimilating students going from
the year institution the fouryear
institution so we know those kind of
conversations have taken place so I I
think it's a question we should leave in
here yeah okay next one how are the
multiple collective bargaining
agreements to be merged oh wow here we
are didn't we have something like that
yes we did yeah yeah the only the only
thing I would the only thing I would add
Jen to the previous questions we've had
on the collective bargaining I would add
compensation benefits and conditions of
employment specifically because they are
are different with respective we when we
talked about the problem of leveling up
salaries where is the retirement system
come in and I think by just qualifying
that the CBA question is an important
one to
do okay yeah that'd be fine Jen uh
number
20 how do you accommodate the
instructional qualifications of Staff
serving the various campuses and student
body accommodate the instruction
qualifications I think the intent there
was remember the question I asked Susan
Wednesday was the the the number of
full-time
faculty full-time instructors Visa that
of adjuncts and I mentioned that there
are about 90 full-time at nhti I think
and 262 adjunct professors and the
question was how does that how does that
relate to the whole instructional and
quality and of of of
instruction both at the at the community
college level Visa that at the uh
fouryear institutions whether or not
there's a change whether or not there's
a the the qualifications for an adjunct
for example is it different than it is
for an adjunct at Keen State because
higher education is moving more and more
to adjunct professors now they've always
had had them they needed them because
you want people from who are
practitioners out in the field to come
in and do some teaching but one of the
dilemmas they've had in in um c
community college is that you've got
adjuncts that are really full-time
professors or full-time instructors that
are teaching five sections for example
not just an occasional section so the
question I I had when I was thinking
about this was how does that relate to
other in institutions throughout the
throughout the higher education
structure here in the
state I went on too much on that I'm
sorry well there there is some
legitimacy to the question or the the
the issue from the stpoint that an
adjunct at Keen may not be paid the same
I don't know as the adjunct in PSU yeah
or or the adjunct in nhti y um
so that is it's getting down into the
negotiating stuff again but um it's it's
probably something that's going to have
to be looked at I don't know if it's
necessary right from the top here it it
can stay in there I have no problem with
it but it's it's probably not going to
be addressed early on here yeah it's
probably one of those things to be you
know when it happens it happen exactly
right I
agree well let's leave it there uh how
can a merge system attract more New
Hampshire high school graduates to
become students in the system we've got
that we've got that number 22 how does a
merge system re respect the various
student profiles of each campus that
gets into the traditional student or you
know that's just coming back or the one
coming for a certificate
program or a badge as Oliver likes to
call it um
uh and Maron raised that question too
from a UNH perspective from a standpoint
of having people come back for a
specific kind of a training Visa you
know a degree program and how that's
going to get managed specifically as you
begin to look at remote learning Etc and
options and whether or not that's a
whole new uh whole new market
opportunity for higher education the
other concern I have with this one is
that we've heard many times the
education committee that 60% of the kids
coming into the community college system
need some form of remediation yeah of
that you know many do not uh achieve
success uh when I've asked the same
question to Mary Jane Steen when she was
there at PSU we don't have any remedial
problems we don't have remedial students
well that you know you know if we're
going to start merging some of this
together is that standard that the
community college has now now going to
be
changed and are we going to see more
kids refuse the opportunity to try to go
for that
education um are we going to lose the
services to support the
remediation uh that are provided now and
we've had different ways according to
when we've talked with Shannon before
and how those are delivered in Beth
Dorian so uh I I think it's a legitimate
question is there any objections to
it Mr chair there's another wrinkle to
that as well some of the community
colleges initially took courses and
broke them into fractions and so what
was three credits at the University was
nine credits at the uh Community College
because they broke it into thirds as a
sort of approach to developmental headed
and so they they took them where they
were and brought them forward but they
gave them more credit for it then the
university would have given and so
that's one of the things that gets
worked out in the department sitting
down with the course descriptions and
trying to me measure it all out that's
just another part of the problem what
you just said Oliver I didn't have a hot
clue about and what you're what you're
saying is that's from knowing what
happens in there you've seen it you've
worked with it and that's why it's
important that I think we have people
that are thoroughly knowledgeable that
when they're starting to look at this
stuff I would miss something like
that yeah well we didn't realize it
either until we finally quietly asked
them around the table uh you know was
this you know done to you know meet the
student and and eventually they owned up
to admitting that they had literally
taken our course with a pair of scissors
and cut the the definitions into a third
each and made each one a three credit
course
okay you learn something every day
yeah okay so next one um so we're
leaving that
there uh number 23 what would the
Integrity uh Integrity impact of the
curtailment of certain programs courses
within the system what would be the
Integrity impact of the C who can you
explain that one Mel yeah I think the
the issue here was that if you were to
cut a particular ular program this kind
of goes back to what Michael was talking
about earlier if if you cut a particular
program out of of the
curriculum what impact does that have on
the on the on the other part of the
program for example let's take a
business CL Business program if you were
to if you to say okay we don't we're
gonna cut this program out of the
business
curriculum what impact might that cut
have on the rest of the of the business
program would it maintain its Integrity
from a standpoint of quality Etc I'm not
wetted I'm not wetted to number 23 but
it was when we begin talking about
cutting stuff uh because of uh uh
student enrollment or cost Etc it was
just in my mind was what impact is that
going to have on the merits of that
particular program within a school or
within a
institution I'm not W yeah I I I I think
we could Pro probably I mean that that's
already within the the the um you know
purview of the college presidents yeah
okay so we can cut we don't have to
worry about that one we got enough how
does a flagship section I'm trying to
rush because I'm trying to get done yeah
I the reason the reason why I raised
this one was what we found in
Connecticut when we discovered that the
University of Connecticut is not part of
the total Connecticut higher education
system it's a part and so that was that
was what kind of in my mind raised the
red flag on what's that what does that
mean when you've got you know UNH right
now Browns it Brands itself as the
premier um research institution in the
state how does that then reflect to all
the other schools that would be in the
system again I'm not wetted to that one
it was just a thought that was in my
mind that came across my notes as I was
referring it so Mel maybe we want to
cast that another way though um and
maybe maybe we can lift some language
from the I think it was the enms uh
report that that did have some careful
consideration for merging systems where
one of the systems included a research
University do you remember that Rick
yeah I do remember that
uh you know the the idea of the what Mel
said though here where the
flagship is seen as something special so
we're not going to it's a research
center and there's so it's not cons it's
it's a separate entity within the system
yeah
um it's it it's all goes underneath how
you're going to structure and organize
your system um it's like the
Commonwealth system down in h
Pennsylvania you know well relates too
to what Don was saying about how P State
created their Innovation section
and you know how does if you're in a big
system does that mean that that kind of
creative stuff goes to the flagship or
does it does is there allow for it to be
in the other institutions within that
system I think that if you were to talk
to pilou State now and they're talking
about the cluster program and the
research they're having every Department
do
now uh and some of them are doing it
with local community organizations some
are doing it with business
uh I don't think research should be
contained just to one institution well
but that's my question yeah what does it
mean to have a flagship Visa the others
we don't spend any we don't need that we
don't need it okay let's let's you know
and we've already answered 25 is we've
already already answered
that and the 26 is on the back so how
would a merger system meet the regional
and Statewide needs of and we we've
we've asked that question we've asked
that question so now we are down to um
can you hear my two-year-old it's time
for a nap out there good it's time for
nap for me I don't know about you guys
but I'm getting there
myself I think Mike with his covid shot
there looks like he's pretty
shot you're muted Michael you're mute
Mike all right I I I know I look
terrible and it is co it's not there's
nothing else I mean I don't have Co I
had a CO shot I know it you got the
wrong shot you should have gone where I
got mine yeah you're pretty pretty good
Rick okay so so now we're trying to
focus on what the uh collaborative I can
speak to what I think is going to happen
with uh uh hb2 and this is just all
conjecture I would I would say at this
point in time that there is probably
going to be some concern conc ER about
uh how the mission of the Community
College
systems are may be impacted by this and
a desire to move slowly until there's
guarantees you know more understanding
um so this is what why I think you're
going to see come out of u a division to
a request for slowing it down and
establishing a coordinating Council
um which would be I don't know how
they're going to be developing the folks
that are on that I I think the it might
come from you know both sides of the the
system both
systems uh I would maybe make a
suggestion that it also allow for um
um those people that like Barbara
Brenham mentioned today there might be
some special to come in with I've heard
uh Mike Moffett talk about you know John
Lynch for example uh I've heard uh
myself talk about Ed McKay for example
um there there there are people out
there that have certain expertise that
from a historical perspective even
though they may not have been there in
the last three or four years they
certainly are aware how it works um so I
I I I don't want to really spell out for
them that the council must be this this
and this one of this one of that and
everything else yeah uh I'd rather that
it just recognized we're in this
business to try to slow it down to look
at these considerations that we've just
identified here and and when they move
forward to fund this and do this they're
doing it with the understanding that
they've also looked at our policy
recommendations or
thoughts agreed take care steps to do it
right yeah yeah and I think I think it's
important too Rick that they recognize
that this coordinating group is going to
need some funding that just to kind of
bring a bunch of Volunteers in without
the resources to bring in some of the
experts because I think one of the
things that that britam really
emphasized this morning was the need to
know what is but also to be out there to
bring people in that can say what could
be in a way so that we don't get hung up
and just trying to uh to Resh Shuffle
the chairs on the on a deck of a sinking
ship here that we need to be able to
look forward as well as understand where
we are right now and that's going to
take some that's going to take some
funding um yeah I think that some some
of the folks perhaps you you probably
could utilize if they're already
employed by the university system or the
community college system but you may
need to bring some specialists in as was
suggested today and and and have some
advice as to what Vermont's doing or
what Maine's doing or what massachusett
or Connecticut has done um to try and
get some insights so we we try to make
the best decision that we can I know to
make a buck you got to spend a buck um
and we and we do we do have people
within the system that have worked in
other systems I mean you've got you know
the president of nhti for example came
from Connecticut she has some experience
Don has experiences so I think you're
right there are we need to identify
folks within the system that have worked
outside that have that experience that
can share what they've learned from
their just just a correction there Mel
gret Gretchen came from Pittsburgh oh
from I'm sorry yeah but but but
absolutely re relevant to the
Pennsylvania discussion um that's right
she's part of the Commonwealth system we
had yeah and we've got Dr um Katherine
Addie out at great um Great Bay from
Connecticut there are a whole host of
people that are knowledgeable that we
have right here in our own State and
this is a i I'd rather see us use people
and invite the specialist in if we need
that but to know our state um so I think
that there also ought to be a
requirement written in this
recommendation that there be a a flight
path towards the goal wherever we're
going that goal of merge but there has
to be reports benchmarks along the way
where there's reporting back
to the
legislature the whether it's the higher
education St study commission or it's
back to the education Committee of the
Senate and the house uh or back to the
speaker and the president uh there has
to be some kind of a report um coming
back so that it just doesn't happen and
all of a sudden we hear here's the
outcome and
you know I think we need to be kept
informed yeah okay hey Rick can you hear
me yeah I can I know we're just asking
questions here not making
recommendations but I would ask the
question should an independent
nonpartisan committee be established to
make recommendations and offer options
and the reason I say that I mean like
you just said there are many many
wonderful people in both systems who can
give wonderful expertise but uh if they
are part of the decision-making process
it would be fatally flawed I think
because if you have University system
people making recommendations or
Community cstem people making official
recommendations they're going to
inevitably I think uh you know uh Veer
towards their own com uh system so I and
I I go back to the the Brack thing that
did work for base closures uh so it's a
question that I would ask because we're
not making recommendations should an
independent on part
committee be generated to offer options
yeah you know I I I'd like to respond to
that I think that you know I'll just
bring it down right to the local level
when when I served as chair of the
select board here we had five different
select board members all from different
but at that time they all were working
for the common good of the
community and I never once heard well
it's not good for my precinct so I'm not
going to vote for that I have enough
faith I I believe in uh the
representation that would be put forward
from either by Susan Huard or by kathern
preventure which you know we got to
understand that this shouldn't be
politics but we need to have people that
are clearly going to willing to get on
as this committee has right
here um I haven't heard politics here
you know I've heard issues and they're
all legitimate issues and considerations
and concerns I think it can happen it
should happen I'm going to lose faith in
our system if we know that the people we
have are so oriented around UNH that
they're going to protect UNH rather than
protecting the whole all the students in
this state I think Susan and Karen are
wonderful I think everybody that is
involved with us are wonderful maybe
maybe they'd be fine uh but I know that
if you've immersed yourself in one
system you understand and you're
invested and understand that system it's
going to be hard not to advocate for
that system uh I mean it's just human
nature maybe it'll be fine but I I worry
about I think that's maybe for me the
biggest question is is uh what people
are going to uh get into the weeds and
make the the tough
recommendations one of one of the things
that hasn't been mentioned Rick is the
need for Staffing of this uh
collaborative group uh because as as we
we know it takes time to arrange for
people to attend meetings taking notes
of the meetings I mean Lord knows the
amount of time Jen has spent working
with the various committees in this
remote in this remote process and let's
let's face it we're g to have to do this
in a remote way and as we found on the
commission uh the school funding
commission it it is was a huge task to
staff this thing to make sure everything
was ready to go and and all that so that
the whoever is the chair of the
collaborative group uh doesn't have to
spend their time making those
arrangements so I would add to the
comments to division two the issue of
Staffing is important now whether it's
done with the current uh the current
research folks that's not our decision
but some staffing decisions need to be
provided for well wouldn't that be with
the transitional monies we've been
talking about yes that that could be
part of it that that would be supportive
of that whole effort and this like we've
talked before you got to spend a buck to
make a buck exactly right but by the way
just just for the information of the
group I just got notification that up
until
2013 the chancellor all the presidents
of the colleges reported to the
chancellor up until
2013 just what I had heard too that
that's what I think edit told
me okay all right okay Mr chairman Mr
chairman could I raise one other issue
yes I think we would be somewhat remiss
if we didn't take this opportunity to
somehow either ask as a question or
invite the existing school systems
universities community colleges all of
them to begin the process of exploring
how their their course descriptions
might be brought into um parallel with
each one another for purposes of
facilitating transfer students good
point it's a process they're going to
have to do anyway at some point and if
we invite them then we take the step of
taking this process into a slightly
forward stepping mode where they're
doing something they're going to need to
do anyway and and it doesn't really cost
them all that
much more time in committees and talking
to each
other I think that's a very legitimate
consideration uh that that's exactly
what Pennsylvania has
done so if you take a a course at the
school that Don Burks was at out in Erie
Pennsylvania it would be the same course
as at Penn
State question about it applying to all
the programs to which you might be
admitted if you
transfer yeah within that system yes yes
with that that's what I was referring to
earlier that I think that's that's an
area that that the two systems could get
a jump start on on that now they don't
have to wait till they're merge to to do
that yeah and it would answer one of the
demands we're hearing from our
constituents yeah yeah you know it's
inter just as a side note if you look at
the Department of Defense
schools if a kid is going to a school in
inch on South Korea and transfers to
vbot in Germany in the fifth grade he's
had he has the same courses as they do
they're they're Universal and by the way
the kids in the dod schools they all
score in the top when you start when you
start doing it but they've got a
universal program and I think what what
what Oliver is saying hm why can't we do
that in higher education
so certainly we could begin with the one
under level 200 level and move up the
lot yeah it gets complicated at the top
I know okay Jen you had you said you had
to get out of here by 2:30 I'm looking
at the clock wall here yeah I've got to
get out um but I do have um Pam smling
has joined the call um and so she'll be
able to help you with anything Technical
and um we'll get any notes back to me
that that is necessary um I can also
give you a call about 4:45 repr Vlad if
that's okay to kind of sure when you
need documents back did you take notes
down on the conversation we just had
regarding this uh coordinating Council
yes okay good are you gonna craft
something for us yeah that's the plan
okay good all right so I'll work on that
this afternoon and just try to get you
something as soon as possible um and
I'll send that to you first represent
vad yes and then and then incorporate
any comments and I'll send it to
everybody else you can send it to
everybody in the committee okay um send
it to me and then I'll look it over very
quickly and if I don't get any really
serious feedback from anybody here I'm
gonna get that shovel it right off to
Karen umberger okay um my only other
question is I was just thinking as we
went along um would you like me to try
to kind of Clump the different points
together in in categories yes if you can
do that it'll be much easier to read
okay yeah yeah thank you all right I'll
be in touch guys
okay six o'clock don't worry about
having to rush Jen okay all right thank
you guys appreciate your help have a
good weekend Jen Thank you Pam oh you're
welcome I'm here I don't know if you
want my video on so I'll stay in the
background so so Rick I got so I got a
uh question about how we're GNA how you
going to are you going to present this
to uh division 2 on Tuesday or should
they just going to receive the the
written report I I will present I I
would welcome anybody doing that with me
uh however it's going to be presented
earlier than that I'm going to be
sending the email out
um uh um to to uh Karen umberger and to
Ken Wier yeah
um a as soon as we get that because they
they're they're uh trying to you know
get everything organized uh they too are
under some considerable uh pressure and
Mel I will call you right after this
this meeting right here to explain some
of that okay which I'm not prepared to
do in a public meeting okay I just I
just think that do you want uh uh do you
want some members of the committee to be
there with you as you present this to
the uh division two yeah what I'll have
to do is find out when they are doing
this section of
H2 um I I I I the support would be
really welcomed um I think it's would be
great if they can see that this report
is coming from a committee which was you
know very uh nonpolitical yeah uh we
were looking at at kids and the
postsecondary systems and and all
recognizing that there's Plus and
minuses and um just want to do things in
a fashion which is you know going to be
a lasting fashion rather than do it a
year or two and then have a a problem
right okay Rick I I I'm not sure this is
going to be relevant but I'm subbing in
for Mary Heath all day on Monday and
that's hb2 I think yeah it is okay
that's that's interesting art good I
I'll be I'll be
there
yeah I'm not going to be available
because I'm gonna be in Boston for a
procedure so um yeah I just got one
question for Mike did have you started
your rash yet
Mike it's gonna take a week Mike I I
really wish M had not talked about
that okay um I think we pretty pretty
much uh got our business done here today
um I I will also be in touch with Ruth
Warden trying to get 187a get going uh
they need to get up to Snuff on this as
well so this report ought to be sent off
to them as well as division
two and into both uh I I think we are
well I I'll just keep it at that for
right
now okay all right great else good okay
guys I thank everybody for hanging in
there and really putting some time into
this pay dividends yeah it's an
important it's an important topic and
it's complex so good effort yeah okay
thank you all guys thanks everything
than very much and have a good afternoon
thank you
bye thank you
Pam you're welcome I didn't do anything
but I'm happy to be here now we were
just about done yeah thank you yeah
wrapped up well take care yep have a
good weekend